so good old Mr Elon Musk has been
ragging on Klaus Schwab in the world
economic Forum quite a bit lately and uh
he's uh ramping things up putting up a
poll saying should the world economic
Forum control the world and so I I dig
it I like Elon Musk speaking out against
these people apparently he claims that
he was invited and he didn't want to go
sounded boring they're claiming now that
he was never invited but anyway you got
all these Elites lining up their private
jets flying into Davos and then
lecturing us on climate change claiming
that you're in fact are the problem so
these are these are nasty people but
we'll talk all about that and then
something else came up because someone
super chatted right before we started
about Bank of America I don't know
exactly what's going on but I saw some
videos where people were saying that
money disappeared from their accounts
and then Luke was mentioning that he's
having weird issues with Bank of America
as well and so I'm like is there a story
here or was this like I don't know
someone have to look into this one
because it sounds really crazy I watched
his videos guys in the branch saying
like where's our money and everybody is
like yo they're saying our money's gone
that's creepy especially considering you
got the world economic World economic
Forum basically saying that there's
going to be a major Cyber attack or
cyber event happening so that's the next
big thing so it's kind of like you know
I'll take their word for it you know
considering who they are and what they
do I'll take their word for it but a
couple a bunch of other stories Greta
tunberg got arrested the other day I
want to talk about that and then we got
uh Matt Gates wants to abolish the ATF
that sounds fun so uh we'll get into
that before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
and support our work as a member you get
access to exclusive uncensored members
only shows Monday through Thursday at 11
PM from this show and I'll tell you why
you know we really do appreciate your
membership my voice is all screwed up I
don't even know why because uh it's been
like oh it's been you know like six days
now and I'm not even sick or anything
it's just not getting better so I took
the um past couple of days morning shows
off which means ad revenue is going to
be in the gutter but because you guys
are members it's actually helping keep
the company running because employees
got to get paid and all that stuff
that's the bulk of our costs like any
business so long as you're a member I'm
actually able to have a sick day and
that's really important for me but I
really appreciate that you guys sign up
at timcast.com clicking that join us
button so we'll have a members only show
coming up for you tonight so uh don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole bunch more
is DC Drano thank you for having me it's
an honor and a privilege who are you
what do you do so I am a former
Hollywood entertainment attorney that
talks [ __ ] on the internet now mostly in
the form of memes but I also just got
back my Twitter after two years of being
suspended thank you Elon Musk and so now
I'm doing it on Twitter as well
interesting and then are you able to
talk about what's going on with you on
Twitter
yeah so I uh when I got banned in 2021
early 2021
um I got this really mysterious phone
call from someone they're like hey hit
me up on Signal and I'm like okay and
they're like you're on a list and I'm
like yeah I assume I'm on all the lists
and uh like no no like you're on like a
government list like Code Orange you're
you're talking too much about election
stuff and I'm like okay well I mean you
know 81 million my my ass I'm gonna keep
talking about it and uh sure enough
couple weeks later I got I got banned
for election misinformation in February
2021. and then Judicial Watch came out
with the results of a foia request that
showed that the state of California was
emailing Twitter saying DC Drano is
spreading election misinformation I am a
licensed attorney in the state of
California and they shut down my free
speech I brought this stuff to Harmony
Dylan and Ron Coleman they took on my
case they even put it in their like
non-profit Center for American Liberty
so they're actually paying a bunch of
the costs and we have been suing for a
couple years and we're in the ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals and we're
awaiting our decision we had our hearing
and so all these Twitter files that is
actually something that we've known
about for a couple years and we're
actually in the pipeline so I'm very
optimistic we should we should get into
that if possible later on in the show
thanks for hanging out man we got Luke
hey guys lots of talk at Davos about
banning red meat that's because they
want you eating Bill Gates moves
creating GMO seed oil fake meat so
that's why I decided to wear my bra
brought to you by fake meat t-shirt that
you could exclusively get on the best
politicalshirts.com soon to be unbanned
on Instagram
uh with the moves so we're very excited
about that you can get the shirt on the
best politicalshirts.com because you do
that's why I'm here thanks for having me
well I'm Ian cross and also happy to be
here just realized DC Drano is the
actual Drano to unclog the drain in the
swamp in DC thanks for clearing that up
for me thank you I just been seeing DC
Drano for whatever reason I hadn't
clicked like that like oh yeah I had my
name on my Twitter when I got it back
and then I did a poll I was like do you
guys want Rogan oh handily or DC Drano
and it was like overwhelmingly we want
DC drain I was like okay fine gotta give
the people what they want do you go you
want to go by Rogan do you go by Rogan
on the show basically yeah whatever
funny story Cassandra sends me an email
and she's like Hey we're gonna have
Rogan on uh you know the 18th or
whatever and I was like what
she was like yeah he's gonna he's gonna
come by and I was like really I was like
you could I'm surprising to hit me up so
then you know we're like oh wait that
Rogan yeah that Rogan uh my full name is
Rogan o'hanley and I was uh searching
like some hater comments on Twitter
recently and someone wrote that Rogan
o'hanley is a old Gaelic term for a sad
hand job
I just thought that was very cool
because Rogan means sad is that or the
first off there is no such thing okay
okay but I did think it was clever and I
posted on Instagram right I like it we
got search pressure yo what's up guys uh
at surge.com
um hope you guys are well this will be a
good show I'm excited to meet a fellow
Hollywood or always who left and kind of
got like you said radicalized out of
what they want you to think yeah looking
forward to it man let's jump into this
first story we got this from timcast.com
we got a couple things actually quote
unelected world government must further
comments on world economic forum meaning
in Davos would be great if someone could
compile a game contest of who said the
craziest stuff between 4chan and the
world economic Forum I love it he
recently put up this uh this Twitter
poll so if you guys are on Twitter you
can go uh click that no button the world
economic Forum should control the world
yes no 1.6 million people said I voted
and 13 so we're looking at like 200 000
people said yes
you know what I've been thinking a lot
about world economic Forum lately and
Klaus Schwab obsessed with like
stakeholder capitalism shareholder
capitalism evolving the system the the
economic and I'm like you know what he's
missing out on his statehood like
statehood is comes before economic your
economic system statehood is a concept
that exists without economics you don't
need and Klaus is obsessed all he
focuses on its economics and the
economic structure of things he's
missing out on the political structure
of things which is I think Paramount is
that we have statehood we have local
Central local government where like you
have decentralized structures of
authority that's key you're missing
embarrassing the pointer that's not what
they want they want centralization they
want all the power in their hands they
don't want statehood they don't want
sovereignty they don't want independence
they don't want you being proud of where
you're from they want to break you apart
they want to play a larger divide and
conquer agenda as they take everything
else for themselves because how else
would they be able to get as rich as
they are without them running larger
Ponzi schemes on everyone else in in
inside of the not only the United States
but the entire world and the car
conversations happening at Davos I've
been paying attention to him they're
creepy they're they're out of the 1984
orwellian hellscape you can't even
imagine the horrors that these people
are describing and they're cheering it
on talking about like it's going to be
incredible when you guys don't have any
red meat when you have mandatory
requirement of of making sure that that
you are reporting your carbon emissions
making sure that there's going to be
regulations on speech regulations on
Bitcoins uh there's going to be Global
cyber attacks there's going to be you
know major attacks against free speech
and they're like yeah this is great this
is awesome we need Central Bank digital
currencies we need uh places where you
can't leave where you're going to be
stuck in with 15-minute sustainable
communities this is absolutely crazy
what they're doing and they deserve to
be countered because their policies are
becoming a law who are these laws
servings what they're serving what's a
15-minute community so they're testing
this actually in the United Kingdom
right now it's where you're going to
need permission to cross over from one
one neighborhood to another where
everything is 15 minutes uh inside of
your community so you don't need a car
so you get to walk or you get to ride
around in your bike to have a car and go
from one Community to another you're
only allowed a certain amount of times
to do that then you need government
permission in order to just travel in
your car and the main idea is to keep
you in a prison to keep you in a grid
where you are stuck and this is a pilot
program that's going to be happening in
a major UK town in just a few years from
now that they're going to be instituting
with surveillance cameras artificial
intelligence facial recognition plate
reading cameras making sure that you are
essentially living in a prison yeah yeah
but but This only affects poor people
right so you know the rich people don't
got to worry about it is that is that is
that well depends how rich are you in
the club are you sacrificing you know
yeah our arms not rich enough you know
what I mean exactly how they like
borders yes a lot of borders and they
want more borders uh in order to control
people better there's a reason Klaus
Schwab says China is the model for the
world that's because they've been
testing a lot of their latest
technocratic technology and enslavement
of humanity in that country now they're
going to be rolling it out everywhere
else what's what's this cyber 911 stuff
they've been talking about they've been
talking about that for a long time they
had a war game a couple months ago where
they actually worked with the Russian
government simulating larger cyber
attacks that were supposed to be
happening on the world and how they
would deal with that this is very
similar to event 201 where a lot of the
fairies a very same kind of central
players in uh covid were talking about a
pandemic situation that they were
training for and drilling for right
before covid happened so a couple months
ago their training uh specifically a
drill called cyber polygon where they
specifically were doing these larger
tests of what's going to happen when
everything in our online infrastructure
gets shut down and is weaponized against
the people how are they going to be
responding to it this as they're saying
and kind of foretelling that their next
kind of bigger psyops the next kind of
bigger terrorist attack is going to be
on line is going to be digital and is
going to be affecting everyone and
potentially could have already started a
couple of days ago especially what would
happen with the FAA with them
essentially shutting down and not
allowing airplane traffic for two hours
in the United States first time ever
since 9 11. as a Cyber attack that did
that right potentially we don't know yet
we don't know exact details here but I
get I get riled up against this this so
much because the writing's on the wall
they talk about this they brag about
this they literally have all these
articles and documents uh where they're
like yes this is how we're going to
implement this vision of you being a
slave and us having all the power over
you sorry you want to say something
on a tangent here no it's an extremely
important information they do like to
tout it it sounds less like uh hey you
guys should all watch out for this in
more of a hey this is what we're
planning to do next so we're just kind
of troubleshooting the social effects
and so it almost seems like oh Bank of
America shut down oh FAA and they just
okay when Airlines go down this is what
they do when they electricity goes out
this when there's no money this so
they're catering to our responses I
believe and I actually tweeted about
this I said hey WF is talking about a
Cyber attack and uh the governments are
talking about it but when we bring it up
they call us conspiracy theorists and uh
Elon actually responded to the tweet and
he just wrote under it starlink
yeah man that's what you ultimately I
don't know if it's unhackable but you
need systems outside the system like
Klaus this top-down Authority thing
doesn't work with statehood you can't
make it happen when local authorities
have control and communication and
delivery of goods like if you have drone
delivery services like we can get Jeff
Bezos Amazon to create like a orbital
drone delivery system along with Elon
starlink I think we're really talking
about some sort of Freedom like well
their enemy is statehood their their
enemy is nationalism their enemy is
pride in in one's country because once
you get rid of that you could allow
people to be internationalists because
when you destroy a nation for the
personal benefit of the few these people
don't care about the United States they
don't care about the Constitution
contrary to a lot of people's beliefs
they hate the Constitution they hate
that people have the First Amendment and
the Second Amendment and they're doing
everything in their power they're and
manipulating people as much as they can
they're doing so many underhanded things
in order to make sure that the rule of
law the Constitution the most important
rights that are extremely rare in human
history are obliterated and destroyed
that's exactly what they did in China
and what they did in China is what
they're going to be doing to the rest of
the world very soon because a lot of
their policies that they called for are
literally being implemented slowly and
surely look what happened to Sri Lanka
they complied that was another major
test of the compliance system Sri Lanka
had a 98 ESG social credit score World
economic Forum saying Sri Lanka is going
to be the best country out there what's
happening to Sri Lanka right now energy
shortages the schools are shut down
businesses are shut down energy
rationing government taxing every little
aspect of your life but they have
diversity are you talking about they
have California or yes this is this is
this is their planned destruction of our
life and this is why California this is
why New Zealand this is why Australia
this is why the United Kingdom the
Netherlands and Sri Lanka are all
adopting the same policies at the same
time top-down centralized control of the
control the demolition of the entire
Western world that's what we're seeing
right now it's serious and the
implications here are going to be very
severe been I think we were talking a
little bit before the show about the
king of England and that his ties to the
world economic Forum I'm not a not too
super he's one of the early kind of
co-founders of the world economic forum
and you'll you'll see him uh it's
actually kind of interesting when they
bring him on stage I don't know if you
guys can find the video but they put
like the fleur-de-lis behind them and
it's like a crown over his head right
when he's speaking he is I think that
the wef I am very confident is his way
of expanding England's imperialist uh
intentions through the back door they're
like oh we don't need to put Redcoats in
every country we just need to control
the top players in government media uh
and business and then we can have a lot
of control you know King Charles uh or
Klaus Schwab he talks about how we have
people in the Canadian Parliament and in
the Canadian cabinets in New Zealand and
Canada New Zealand and Australia are all
constitutional monarchies ultimately
subject to the authority of King Charles
and which three countries were the most
oppressive during the cover lockdowns
with the mandatory vaccines with you
know vaccine passports it was those
three countries and Israel concentration
camps China really I think but the thing
about China is they're so Western
countries remember when those three kids
escaped from that uh was it Howard
Springs facility and then all these like
woke people were like no no no it's not
a concentration camp it's just for
people who are sick and they're posting
like bikini-clad women likes like like
you know looking all happy meanwhile
three native like uh indigenous
Australian kids like through burlap
sacks over the barbed wire and tried to
climb out and Escape because they were
forcefully relocated and they had
checkpoints because of that they they
literally locked down entire cities
looking for these three kids which were
a danger to society they were
imprisoning people and putting them in
quarantine camps because they had
disagreements and arguments with police
officers who are just sick of someone
and said you know what you tested
positive even though they did not and
those photos are actually from the
Olympics and a lot of the Australian
Olympic team were using that facility
previously before and that's where they
got all the pictures of all the hot
babes but essentially it was just uh you
know a camp that the government it
detained you for as long as they wanted
to without you having any kind of
recourse is an important point to be
made though
look at what happened with Claire Lehman
from Colette she was this free speech
advocate
living in Australia then Australia goes
full death star and she immediately
Falls in line and says never it's all
okay everything they're doing is
completely fine you're all wrong that's
how quickly you know some of these
people's uh Integrity holds up if you
ever wanted to know what it like what
it's like what you're gonna do when
tyranny takes over you just found out
the last three years yep how you
responded that was the greatest
psychological operation ever conducted
on Humanity in the history of the world
and if you went through that and obvious
you know if you didn't get the jab or if
you resisted the mass or whatever you
know pat yourself on the back because
that's quite impressive I think America
I think they're actually I think we
actually achieved a huge Victory and I
do want to give a lot of credit to the
Canadian truckers they set the wheels in
motion but I think they're like crap we
still had despite all that despite
trillions of of propaganda
thirty percent forty percent of
Americans did not fully comply and it's
probably going to be worse the second
time around yeah yeah it was like
inoculation for me it was the rat hope
experiment we've talked about it you
familiar with it
no dude takes three cylinders full of
water and some rats puts the rats in the
cylinders they swim for 15 minutes then
give up and die he then takes another
group of rats puts them in the cylinders
they swim for 15 minutes give up but
then he grabs them and pulls them out
dries them off lets them rest puts them
back in the second time they swam for 60
hours oh because when they had hope they
were they they they said I'm not going
to give up the first group of rats were
just like I have no idea what's
happening I'm tired this is it I'm done
second group of rats were like I will be
saved the hand will come back and they
kept swimming it's the first time I've
been appreciating being called a rat
that's crazy now imagine the experiments
of the CIA are working on right now that
we don't even know about probably with
very similar situations very similar
circumstances but instead of rats
they're probably doing it well they're
human beings that's what people think
about the lockdowns the lockdowns were
the first 15 minutes and then everybody
started to lose their minds then they
okay everybody we're going back to
normal everybody come back out come back
out they're gonna re-lock down so the
hypothesis goes and this time they're
going to be like don't don't worry just
like last time we'll we'll lift the
lockdown soon it's coming it's coming
but people will go 300 times longer in
lockdown I got a little bit of a
different take from that is that the the
willingness to resist and then their in
inability to enforce it is the Hope like
that's us getting pulling ourselves out
of the tank realizing like oh you don't
have to submit to this yeah personally I
just see things a little bit differently
I don't think they're going to try to
launch another kind of pandemic from
here I think it's going to be digital I
think there's going to be an attack on
our infrastructure it's going to lead to
a lot of chaos and then they're going to
come in and say hey it's dangerous to
have an open and free internet we need
to take control of it and that's the
last thing that's the last step that
they need fully controlling the internet
fully taking it over from people like
Elon Musk and other individuals that are
still allowing Free Speech everything
and saying this is now in our control
for your safety and your health and
well-being just one more point before we
move on to this particular story uh
Robert Kennedy Jr actually just did a
very fascinating interview that I just
uh retweeted talking about how the
central controllers people at the CIA
during covid weren't looking up for your
best interest weren't talking about and
and making studies and looking into how
to help people how to give them early
treatments he goes on and talks about
how the CIA used the covid-19 response
to increase their top-down government
authoritarianism and totalitarianism and
had this as an opportunity to run many
psychological operations to see what
they could get away with this is Robert
Kennedy Jr fascinating video just
tweeted about it um I want to pull up
this story because this is this is
freaky stuff man this is from click to
Houston News Guard certified they say
what's going on with Bank of America
social media users call out Financial
giant over missing money
they say social media erupts from the
everyday consumer to heavyweight
political and business figures the
financial Giants timeline was flooded
with complaints in the form of posts and
mocking memes one commenter appeared to
ask the question that everyone seemingly
wanted to know what's going on with Bank
of America
apparently they were trending after many
customers discovered that money was
missing from their accounts the
concerned consumers shared their
experiences online
down detector and consumer website
reported the issues happening with Bank
of America around 10 30 a.m you want to
know what's really funny
I learned this lesson very important
lesson I think everybody needs to know
do you know what your bank account is
do you want to notice do you know what
it is my guess is it's a computer text
file yeah it's a text.txt the amount of
money you have in your bank is quite
literally just input text there's no
cash there's no gold literally nothing
and I learned this the hard way
because I bought a truck and uh paid I
we we financed it and then after a few
months I paid I went to pay off like I
paid off the whole thing
three months later I get a phone call
and they're like we're gonna repossess
your truck because you never paid the
bill I was like talking about I paid the
I paid the whole thing off and they're
like no you didn't
both Banks my bank which I did the
transfer from and their Bank said we
have no record of where this money is my
bank said when we do the transfer out
all we do is write minus the number and
press enter and it subtracts from your
account and then they confirm our our
subtraction and they do the addition the
problem was the other bank didn't do the
plus so the money vanished disappeared
that's right completely disappeared
where'd the money go and they were like
we don't know and I'm like I don't
understand and then and then you know I
basically had a guy say to me like he
didn't say it like this but what do you
think your money in the bank is there's
no cash in there you do not have a a box
full of cash in a vault they quite
literally just type a number and press
enter yeah it's promissory notes no no
no no no no it's not it's not even a
crypto like you think with Bitcoin
there's there's there's an encryption
key behind that that at Bitcoin it
exists you could hold it there's
something there at least a string a hash
code with your bank literal nothing the
only thing that exists is The Ledger
itself
and when the when the Ledger doesn't
reflect the actual transaction it
doesn't matter because the other bank
went we don't know we don't have the
money and my bankside we don't have the
money either your money is just gone
it's so hackable that is so controllable
to think that these product companies
have secret text files that have your
money on it that they can change at will
behind the scenes or that someone else
could hack it well like at that point I
do believe cryptos more secure even
though you could lose it it could go to
zero they're not at least diversify your
assets not necessarily just what you
invest in but having crypto having cash
in the bank having cash at home and like
you mentioned a few days ago having gold
I mean it when things go south
let me you want to have tangible assets
just in case I'll tell you guys a story
when I was uh when I was like 20 I think
I was like 21.
my buddy overdrafts and he's like why
did I overdraft this this doesn't make
sense what happened was in Chicago there
was this big Scandal where the CTA the
the public transit was double charging
people so we're broke
he's got 30 bucks in the bank he spends
20 bucks
that his paycheck comes in on a Friday
he should have 180 bucks instead he's
like negative 200. and he's like what
happened well apparently what happened
was the CTA double charged him putting
him negative then he got hit with
overdraft fee overdraft fee bought a
pack of gum for two dollars
right stupid so then he he accumulates
all these overdraft fees his paycheck
doesn't cover him he's trying to buy
things he's getting more and then also
he's negative and and I could be totally
wrong about this because it's been 20
years but I'm pretty sure we went to the
bank this is a crazy story
and we're hanging out and he sits down
with this this like manager guy in a
suit and he says you know he pulls up
his his bank account he's pointing at
things he was like look look right there
like it like CTA charged me three times
like that caused me to go negative then
my paycheck came in and the guy was just
like okay okay he turns the monitor
around and then he starts typing stuff
in he spins it back around and it says
like negative 400 and he puts the cursor
on the negative and clicks backspace and
then says how does that look and then my
friend's like uh okay and then he was
like there you go and hit enter did
something and like we were like wait
what just happened does he now have 400
bucks okay get this
the Bank closed down a few weeks later
so I have to wonder what may have
happened was this guy knew he was
getting laid off the manager and so he
was like screw these people and just
transferred money but but I I'm almost
kind of like was he screwing with us
because there's no way he can do a hard
input and just change something I think
he can they have discretionary like a
person on the phone can be like yeah
I'll overwrite your 35 charge but they
only have a certain limit that they can
overwrite and then the manager is
probably like 500 per customer per week
or something you can we used to be
backed by gold I mean this is a
relatively the last hundred years
central banks Federal Reserve I'm sure
everyone watching has knowledge on that
but I mean there used to be when you
said hey I'd like to take out money they
had gold to to trade it in one one quick
note on the rat thing I actually
misinterpreted it that oh they put them
in they'll last longer I think we the
people would actually like if they're
gonna put us back on we just bite their
hand a lot like I don't think I'd go
back swimming
in that tank for 60 hours
a lot of people they want to get people
to put themselves in the tank I think a
lot of people would also be like we
don't think of how many people don't
trust the CDC the FDA big for I I was
like never like that really before if
you trust the government now you haven't
been paying attention and you had your
head in uh in in the sand for the last
three years I didn't trust the
government but like I thought at least
the medical people were generally pretty
squared away let's let's add the banking
component into what's going on now with
people like there's a viral video of
people in a bank and they're like
where's our money right
think about what can happen if this
cyber event is everyone's money
disappearing what happens afterwards no
everyone then calls the government and
says I want my FDIC insured whatever and
now all of a sudden you are on your
knees in front of some government BS
being like please sir may I have another
please regulate this
industry more please now we need a
central bank digital currency now we
need a universal basic income and that's
one of the perfect ways to implement
they're going to come out and they're
going to be like we don't know what
happened it was a Cyber attack the whole
the whole it's the Russians The Ledger
has gone down it was Russia who did it
what we're going to do is we're going to
give everybody five thousand dollars in
their accounts for the time being so you
can have basic Goods all the poor people
are going to be like yay and all the
rich people and all the middle class
people are going to be like my life is
being destroyed we need to put in a new
Patriot Act but this one's going to have
a dollar sign after it Patriot Act for
money
what do you guys think about Patriot Act
gold I think that the Central Bank
digital currency that they're talking
about doing is probably going to happen
at some point and it'll probably usurp
the dollar or become part of the dollar
and like a dollar bill will represent as
a token but what do you guys think about
like a United States decentralized
crypto like Bitcoin but like just backed
by you the United States government
totally decentralized what does that
mean would it get backed by the threat
of being drone bombed yeah exactly
because I was like what would I say to
Congress like how do we fix the economy
I'm just grasping at straws but
obviously our money used to be gold but
now it's the threat of being blown up
literally and it's all you know the
money everything is drifting electronic
right so California is kind of like a
predictor of things to come in terms of
the leftist agenda here they want your
car to be electric they want your stove
to be electric they want your money to
be purely electric why because you can
control things that are electric yeah
you have the grid I wouldn't say
drifting I would say it's like you know
help reading yeah
word so maybe instead of it being backed
by force it would just be like Amer you
can buy American Goods with this
cryptocurrency in addition to the US
dollar and then it was DT
um yeah something like that but like
it's back I think by the dollar they
have to have dollar reserves that's
tethered like literally I think that's a
state yeah that's tether yeah that's it
stays the exact value as the dollar so
it could be but I think it would take
off and become more valuable than the
dollar just because it's digital none of
you always the power could always go out
and then you're Back to Basics where
that's why cash you could never I don't
think you'd ever should get rid of Cash
ever but I don't imagine I'll put like
trying to put those uh what do they call
those little barcodes on each dollar
bill
QRS or or I'm talking about the little
metal strips that they put in your
credit card they're like they're printed
from like foil but they can magnetically
measure where you're at and all that
track you well there's also a war on
cash and many places already have
stopped accepting it in many many
businesses as well and they don't have
the exact change for it and yeah
well I think I don't know I have to look
into that but there's a better idea
there's microchips that you could shove
up you know what and then you have to be
you know attracted uh and it's inside of
you and and they'll know that it's going
to be your transaction and you have to
be probed every time you want to use uh
you know the money and then they know
exactly it's coming from you to uh
whatever else you're buying and then
they have a perfect record and then
they'll know exactly how many taxes you
have to pay they'll know exactly what
you're buying they'll share it with all
the big uh corporations that will know
your your consumer activities which will
help them sell you better products in
China what's the libertarian solution
because the US dollar is a real status
thing like you can go to Wyoming and buy
groceries at a grocery store there with
the US dollar because the American
Military is like you better or we're
gonna and we are in control and everyone
is using the US dollar here there's
there's a reason Libertarians and and
the Ron paulers have been screaming
about the dangers of the U.S federal
reserve for so many years if you look at
Ron Paul even before the major financial
problem one of the things that he was
making arguments against is the Federal
Reserve printing money out of thin air
this was before 2008 that it has been a
staple position of many Libertarians of
many anti-statists saying hey this
creature from Jekyll Island is a big
problem because they could literally
create inflation they could create
deflation but they know what's going to
happen so they could game the market so
they are always the winners and you will
always be the loser and this is what
they've been doing for decades on
decades on decades and this is why the
Libertarians have been talking about
this because you you get rid of that
Central Bank just like Thomas Jefferson
did that he gets put on the 20 bill but
but you get rid of that you allow people
to have more freedom and you're not
controlled by the whims of banksters
well let's talk about this controlled
opposition I got this tweet here from
chairwell that says Peter Thiel bashes
Greta and the autistic Children's
Crusade in his address at the Oxford
Union blaming environmentalism for some
of the greatest crises of our time
andyway reports that's a bold statement
from from Peter teal about Greta it's
interesting though because you know
what's what's Peter thiel's deal I mean
isn't he like a Davos group or no he's
not he's not I think that stuff probably
was former Davos I mean I think he's
kind of old-school Silicon Valley right
when Silicon Valley started these guys
were like Tech Libertarians like we're
given a voice to the people and then
money and Banks and all that got
involved
um you know I was going to say to your
point there's three things you can't
audit the Federal Reserve our elections
and the dod budgets so so we got Greta
tunberg which is I guess what blanket
controlled opposition fairly obvious to
anybody she doesn't protest in China she
protests the West which is doing
everything that's power to get rid of
carbon emissions Peter Thiel comes out
and and bashes Greta calling it Greta
and the autistic Children's Crusade but
this guy I thought I thought Peter you
know I know Peter thiel's had some good
opinions but I thought he was like
Bilderberg he well I mean he just
sponsored JD Vance and Blake Masters for
Senate which I think is a testament to
him I was out of Blake Masters
fundraiser in my Miami at Peter thiel's
house and he gave a quick speech and I
was admittedly like I was like wait
Peter Thiel is like a Silicon Valley guy
Facebook like come on I'm not and his
his speech which you know early PayPal
was great current PayPal sucks early
PayPal was amazing yeah uh and his
speech blew me away three minutes and I
was like oh he's a good guy now and I
think we've seen that with Elon Musk
with you know Joe Rogan like these guys
they're kind of getting more and more
emboldened with Tim Poole
um I I think uh he said we have about
three years left to save America from a
communist takeover Peterson
I mean he has a very last year he has it
too he has a very interesting career
especially what happened with BuzzFeed
especially him being ousted by them and
then kind of getting retribution through
Hogan him coming out and supporting
Donald Trump especially during the RNC
was pretty ballsy too but he has a very
interesting kind of career he's also
with palantir with Alex karp who was at
Davos uh today specifically talking
about how he is a progressive helping
the intelligence agencies uh and and
working on AI technology that will help
track down Russians in in the
battlefield but also given this
technology to the U.S intelligence
agencies and how a lot of progressives
should be happy that he's doing so
because he's stopping a lot of
right-wing terrorist attacks but that's
you know Alex carp another Bilderberg
member who's working with Peter Thiel uh
on palleteer I talked to Peter Thiel
twice at Bilderberg already uh and he is
a Bilderberg steering committee member
so there's a lot of mystery there
there's still a lot of questions I would
love to have a bigger discussion with
him he's kind of a little mysterious
figure but but I think definitely there
deserves to be a bigger conversation to
be had with him uh because he's he's
interesting I I agree too and you know
look we're doing the whole coffee shop
thing the cafe skate shop physical
location stuff and it's and it's
particularly inexpensive relative to
um other businesses like setting up a
coffee shop is is not as expensive as
setting up like a media company I bring
this up because I wonder with Peter
Thiel being worth what is he like two
billion dollars I'm genuinely curious
I'm not saying he's doing nothing but
I'm wondering if he really feels this
way about how we got three years to save
this country what is he doing and again
not saying he took nothing I'm genuinely
curious like what are his approaches and
and strategies with all of his his
resources to try and save this country
if he even is I I've only seen what has
been public I mean you know it kind of
Bilderberg he was on the Facebook board
right and you would you'd think oh
that's bad because Facebook is very
censoring and they kick the president
United States off but it's also kind of
good because we want some representation
on that board too so you know there is a
kind of a flip side to it but all I can
attest to I'm not a Peter teal expert
but he did back those two Senate
candidates he put I think he was like
the second or third biggest GOP donor he
recognizes that the time at this in this
country where we're at and um I I
imagine he'll be a big supporter in 2024
but I don't know fully what his plan is
the palantir thing's interesting it's
basically spy Tech and it's like new
21st century spy Tech from what I know I
know very little about it uh except that
it's spy Tech I just want to make a
correction really quick it wasn't
BuzzFeed it was Gawker I apologize no uh
with Peter Thiel and Hogan uh the Hogan
Law oh yeah oh right right so I
apologize I misspoke what was that
lawsuit to clarify really quick Gawker
published uh sex tape of Hulk Hogan the
hawkster yeah and it was so brutal they
should not have done that and uh but
they were like oh it's what we do and
Peter Thiel then funded the lawsuit and
it's because Gawker outed him as gay
okay but the thing that thing is it's
crazy is like he does work around the
world he could be killed in some of
these places yeah Peter like the Middle
East especially you know which is which
is a huge danger to him and it wasn't it
wasn't a newsworthy story it was a
gossip story that they tried to of
course hurt him over which was again
ridiculous but sorry so big thing that
people need to to discuss because they
have a big presence in the intelligence
community and the intelligence Community
the FBI the CIA depends on them a lot
yeah I invest I was advised hey palantir
invest so I did I like made like 10
times my money on this freaking thing in
the beginning Ian comes up to me one day
I'm in this was like a year and a half
before covet it was like right around
when covet was beginning no early 2012.
you you came we were here oh yeah I'm in
my front office and then you walk up and
you're like dude my friends are saying
you got to buy a bunch of palantir stock
and I was like I'm not going anywhere
near there yeah yeah I know I was like
when it comes to investment it's not
about what you believe in it's about
what you know is going to make you money
unfortunately sickeningly I do that
every once in a while you can get really
rich really quick I sold it all but
anyway I think what's happening is I
brought this up last night in the after
show that maybe the CIA the FBI the NSA
are the good guys and the we are
inadvertently have been cannibalizing
yourself is there a mute button because
it's only good relative to what else
there is the other options which are the
CCP the world economic forums a whole
bunch of easy so it's like the liberal
economic order versus bricks
they are already bought out by the CC P
I think the CCP is so embedded I mean we
already oh social credit scores we
already have that go ask someone like
Laura Loomer Alex Jones yeah but like
the CCP is the testing grounds for the
elites to push a lot of their unpopular
policies to see the compliance levels
that they want to bring to the West uh
and this is like you know Ian I think
you have the Twilight Saga view of
werewolf and vampires whereas like the
the classical view is if a werewolf and
a vampire are fighting each other over
you it's because they want to eat you
not because they want to date you and so
like the way you're describing like
maybe they're the good guys insofar as
worse bad guys I'm like yeah that's like
you're imagining sparkly vampires who
are just like I'm so in love with you I
promise they're not the guys the lower
level people are generally good people
working hard and want to bust bad guys
the guys at the top are evil as corrupt
as they can yeah
Alex carp's uh the CEO of palantir had a
lot of interesting comments today at
Davos he was talking about how incutel
was one of the first kind of startups
for a lot of these larger bigger tech
companies he was talking about how the
CIA the FBI the dod were all involved
and now how a lot of these bigger tech
companies are more aligned to the West
uh because of that he was going off and
talking about how they are creating
algorithms that palantir that are
specifically used to quote Target
Russians on the battlefield and later he
went on and said the US government has
our software and uses it very
aggressively that's Alex carp today
um CEO of palantir at Davos today very
eye-opening comments to say the least
yes I don't I don't think anybody at the
NSA is a good person not a sing not a
single one I just don't know them all
and I know companies aren't monoliths
the NSA is is a fourth amendment
violating organization there's no
question I don't think anybody at the
NSA is like sitting there saying I know
we're in violation of the the rule the
law of the land of this country in
violation of our Oaths to uphold the
Constitution but oh well like there's
there's no circumstance or they don't
know because they
if you don't if you weren't educated
about the Constitution you wouldn't know
that's called the banality of evil yeah
so these people and then when you when
they when they learn they're like oh oh
oh I'm not doing that anymore like
people will wake up you ever see that
Family Guy joke where it was uh there's
a murder in prison and then he had he's
holding a knife and he like pokes
himself and goes whoa is that what I'm
doing to people I deserve to be in here
like like as if they don't know I don't
know maybe maybe but it's just like dude
look the chicken poster just fell oh no
okay but it's an omen the NSA is
listening literally a lot of poster it's
a painting okay very nice painting I'll
fix it it's a guy behind behind the wall
with a glass listen they were they were
you know
yeah you know I'm not going to use Nazi
Germany as an example let's use Soviet
Russia yeah there were a lot of people
working for the gulag who are just like
look I don't know what this guy did they
told me he's a bad guy and his crime was
that he he said we deserve better
there's a guy sitting in his apartment
and he's like looking at how awful
everything in the Soviet Union and he
goes outside and he goes I think we
deserve better and then you know the
gulag guy says you go arrest him and
then some low-level dude some low-level
dude goes he's a criminal you know I
don't know is that is that is that a
good guy no he's taking someone and
putting him in in what we call the gulag
yeah or the cultural or the cultural
revolution in in China where literally
there was walks of Shame against
capitalists against individuals who had
private property because those were the
ones that were responsible for
everyone's pain and suffering and they
literally humiliated them tortured them
in public squares with people cheering
it on dude that's what they're doing
those are order followers those are back
the blue people that should be
questioned that's what the exact same
thing they're doing to the j6 prisoners
yep it's the same thing you got to go
and bend the knee and say that you don't
like Trump you don't like uh you know
you don't believe in what he was saying
and you know humiliation but I mean we
just had MLK Day right yeah uh under
Trump they released the letter from the
FBI telling MLK to commit suicide I mean
it didn't didn't I mean this is what
people have been saying that the fbis
would have killed them I mean yeah no we
don't have like there's a civil court
there was a civil case in 1999 where a
jury found the U.S government complicit
in the assassination of MLK and the MLK
family won that particular lawsuit yes
I'm gonna take their word for it and so
and so you know we have all this history
think of uh JFK and RFK they spied on
MLK under the FBI the doj Attorney
General was RFK he signed off on it they
have a picture of a signature the
president was JFK these are the greatest
civil rights leaders of our time and
they're the ones that spied on and told
him to kill himself and then you know
what they did Herbert Hoover was the
director of the FBI they named the FBI
building after him another guy
the guy go ahead uh
under Jackson on the 20 Bill exactly
just painted the central banks yeah and
and then
that they make people worship the cross
when that's the thing they killed him
with but but the the Hoover thing is
important here because a lot of people
are saying it was actually Hoover who
was responsible for this who had a lot
of skeletons in his closet and was
allegedly also a cross-dresser but the
FBI did so many Sinister things
especially under cointel probe a lot of
people don't even uh know this but they
had full on disinformation
um organizations and psyops running so
people wouldn't organize together and
what they did to the MLK was it just
spying on him wasn't just writing
letters saying hey kill yourself they
they they were watching his every move
they knew that he cheated on his wife
took that information and when MLK was
in jail they went to his wife and said
here's the evidence here's the tapes of
MLK talking to his mistress divorce him
that is just absolute evil their number
one tactic in a movement is to go in and
divide it let's go and tell probe I want
to pull up this a story from Fox News a
lot of people were talking about this
the video of Greta tunberg getting
arrested sending Twitter into a frenzy
time for many of us to stand up and you
got this clip where she's being carried
away with a smile on her face and then I
don't know if we we yeah we do have it
here people are saying it's staged
because you can see her laughing and
smiling with with some guy as the cops
are just standing there with her and
then they eventually just walk away and
she's not being carried I don't think
it's staged I don't I the cops were
probably told okay get the protesters
out of here I think it was staged in so
far as almost all non-violent Civil
Disobedience has staged as in protesters
will call the police and say hey we're
going to go here we're going to protest
just so you know then the cops say okay
we're gonna come arrest you and say okay
and then you can press but here's the
real story the real story is that Greta
tunberg's friends attacked a bunch of
journalists look at this from Andy no at
the autonomous Zone in luzoreth Germany
militant leftist an anti-fun climate
extremists surrounded and attacked
journalists
he's a great tunberg's friends huh
there's something I think people need to
bring up because I'm not I'm not playing
these games we've talked about the
banality of evil if Greta tunberg is
going to be associating with these
people if she's going to be organizing
protests and inviting these people and
if she will not call this out then she
is complicit and she supports it I
remember playing eco-terrorism in
Civilization 2 it was my first exposure
as a young man to eco-terrorism and I
was like oh these people are protective
Sif too you could create eco-terrorist
care or might have been the expansion to
Sith too it had been expansion yeah and
you could create a character that was an
eco-terrorist that could go and I was
like oh they're defending the planet but
they're called terrorists these are good
units I want eco-terrorists on my in my
Army because they're valuable and I'm
like wait a minute this is all why do
they call them terrorists if they're
protecting the Earth but I think Greta
is willing to use violence or associate
with people using violence because she
thinks it's that drastic you see that
flag that's the flag of violent leftists
leftist violence yeah and I mean hey
there are times and places that people
have been destroying things to the point
where you have to use violence to stop
them from destroying it but I don't
think the uh the global ecosystem is in
that state right now I'm not I'm not
going to put I'm not going to make a
moral judgment on um on the protests I
am going to make a fact statement Greta
tunberg's group violently attacked
journalists
is it a is it confirmed that they're all
in the same group were they just all
their kind of disparately Desperately
what does that even mean like they were
all there of their own volition didn't
know each other but some people were
violent some other people there there's
one protesting
climate stuff
well let's let's watch the video what
game I'm not going to play
is that these these leftists have long
done this where they quote unquote
respect A diversity of tactics and then
they'll they they will all feign uh
ignorance and reject responsibility for
what they organize which is violent
attacks on journalists it happens all
the time and then you'll get an
organization and it'll be called like
you know save the planet
and then when antifa shows up and gets
violent they go oh well that was us yes
they are otherwise you'd kick them out
otherwise when that when that one crazy
dude shut up in Portland started doing
the Nazi salute or whatever they threw
him out and then all the woke media ran
pictures claiming he was at their event
it's like yeah getting kicked out they
said get the F out they won't kick these
people out they want them there to
respect their diversity it concerns me
man Greenpeace they would go you know
sink sink boats and blow up oil tankers
I don't know I don't think Greenbush
ever did that destroyed their Bridges or
pacifists I'm pretty are you sure I'm
pretty sure I've seen how terrorists
what happened with green Greenpeace sea
shepherds are the ones that actually
don't fight
Greenpeace they had a uh the French
government bombed one of their boats or
something like they blew it up now I'm
not saying green beans are good dudes
you know they do not they they will get
like water guns and they'll climb onto
boats and they'll wave flags and do
better drops but I'm pretty sure
Greenpeace isn't going around bombing
anybody or anything like that sea
Shepherds at hacked at Sea vessels
attacked so these guys are known as yeah
there's like those are pirates yeah but
pirates for Earth for planet Earth well
there's like a whole city I did say butt
pirates but pirates for planet Earth
yeah well okay so I still didn't see the
the attack because I see a lot of social
media posts to come up being like man
attacks dude and thing and I'm like what
did he do he got up in his face and
yelled at him that's not attack well if
you saw there like threw it on the
smartphone that they were using to
record they hear they kicked him in this
video yeah kind of mild harassment stuff
you know that's one thing I give antifa
a little credit for is that they don't
go too overboard they just kind of
pepper spray and beat you up a little
bit they don't actually shoot you or
stab you yeah
you know what the one thing I can say is
if I was going to have any sympathy for
antifa it's because we all are sick and
tired of journalists because like
they're just liar like they they lie for
corporations they lie for advertisers
yeah and if it's not them it's their
bosses who do it so it's just like
I get why antifa's mad they hate
journalists because journalists lie all
the time yeah but I'm opposed to
violence so like if Greta tunberg wants
to go to some protest and associate with
this then I'm going to call it like I
see it that's that's her group I'm not
saying she she organized that group I'm
not saying I'm saying she's with them so
you think she has a responsibility to
speak out against us right now
absolutely like when that dude showed up
to in in Portland I forgot the guy's
name and he started yelling the n-word
they said get the out of here like dude
it's tough for especially on the right
because the media will lie anyway and
and they will protect the left right now
I assure you Media Matters is like
writing something up whether like Temple
lies and claims gratitude versus
violence or something and and that's the
challenge but I'm I'm I'm I'm not going
to play any games if you are like hey
everybody meet me here and then a bunch
of violent lunatics attack journalists
and then you're like don't look at me I
mean put yourself in the reporter's
shoes right you're there to try to
report say you're coming from a good
place you're just trying to cover what's
going on here because the corporate
media is very sympathetic to What's
Happening Here Al Gore is promoting
Greta tunberg today right so you're
there covering what's going on and then
you got some people coming up you don't
know who they are you don't know if they
have weapons start kicking you slapping
your camera throwing you down saying get
out of here assaulting you slapping you
punching you and and whenever you put
your hands on somebody again you
shouldn't do that I covered a lot of
different protests faced a lot of
different in insane situations I got
assaulted I got jumped a couple times I
got beat up a couple times but uh the
best thing that I saw was in Hong Kong
where where of course people there were
protesting against the Chinese
government the Chinese government was
using fake press as a way to get photos
and videos of protesters and then arrest
them and ship them away forever what did
the Hong Kong protesters do they didn't
assault journalists they didn't beat
them up but they figured out ways to
kind of do their thing to of course have
their face covered but also use
umbrellas in a way that prevented any
kind of conflict or escalations when
they were changing into black blocks
since they were using Black Block
tactics they used it in a way to not
force or hurt anyone but but obfuscate
their identity because there was a real
threat for the Chinese government coming
in and disappearing people and they did
it in a way that we didn't need any of
this nonsense any of this kind of threat
or assault of of journalists which we
should always try to avoid and speak out
against let's not lose sight of the
irony of a flag standing for
anti-fascism beating up journalists for
covering their well I love that there's
a meme where it's like a leftist yelling
just because the Nazis call themselves
socialist doesn't mean they're
socialists and then holding the idea of
a flag and be like of course we're
anti-fascist so then it's in our name
yeah yeah don't dig your word for it
whether you said Hong Kong
um Rebellion what would you even call
that an uprising uh resistance well the
Chinese state was coming in and not
keeping their promise that they had with
the UK government that they were going
to transition Hong Kong to China in a
very slow way the Chinese government did
it in a very fast way and was of course
also destroying a lot of key
institutions in Hong Kong and a lot of
the larger uh apparatuses and
institutions that provided a lot of
people Liberty they were getting rid of
that people protested and then there was
a violent Crackdown on the protests and
um it was just insane covering that
situation because it was truly so much
different than covering a lot of the
western protests that I've seen in
Greece or in Paris or even inside of the
United States where a lot of the the
things were totally opposite I heard
that they were putting crazy chemicals
and like fire hoses with like blue ink
and pepper and they would spray it and
stick on your skin yeah sticks on your
stick for skin for a while it makes you
blue so they know who I got hit with it
a little bit and I and I felt that stink
for a very long time some people were
covered in it I just got hit with it a
little bit just covering the protest
there I was there for some of the most
violent most insane interactions where
there was uh you know it's just these
people getting seriously hurt and dying
in on the streets these American and
European antifa are spoiled little brats
yeah go to go to go to Turkey go to
Brazil it was an experience when I was
in Brazil because I've been you know
Luke and I both in pepper sprayed and
tear gas Ad nauseam literally you know
throughout the United States and it's
like you get gas it sucks you cough
whatever you get pepper spray when
you're taking a shower later it burns
when I was in Brazil I was like oh
they're tear-gassing everybody and then
as soon as the gas hit me like my nose
and eyes just like mucus tears it was
like 10 times more powerful yeah and it
was just like your nose was just
spraying mucus I took my I took my sock
off and jammed it in my mouth to be able
to keep breathing and I was like damn it
was bad yeah in the United States it was
like the lowest tier irritant and it's
just like you know other countries don't
give a damn the reason I brought up
heavy stuff in Israel uh especially uh
in in Gaza they they use like it's a
very serious stuff uh not just CS gas
but uh also uh there's like a skunk
um gun as well they use some Next Level
stuff there which is just crazy it
concerns me that it's being tested on
the on the rioters or would you call
them protesters but okay so you said
they got black block they were dressing
in Black Block in yeah Hong Kong do you
think that was just were they violent
Black Block violence uh depends on the
on on the circumstances situation there
was a couple instances where uh they
stormed a government building they
stormed Parliament there was also a
couple instances where people were
getting assaulted and beat up but not as
much as of course a lot of the western
protests so there was that as well do
you think they were Justified I don't
think so I think anytime you try to use
force and violence against someone else
to enforce your ideas you're losing and
you're in the wrong American Revolution
well that's a totally different thing
that wasn't a protest right yeah yeah it
started off as a protest in Boston
Harbor but but you have the right new
Defender hold on hold on the American
revolutionary period was 20 years it
wasn't just a protest in Boston Harbor
there's a whole bunch of stuff yeah I
know there was the Boston Massacre
people were being killed soldiers were
barging into people's homes and taking
people's food and sleeping there and
then the the founding fathers wrote
sternly worded letters for years to the
king being like yo please stop yeah you
could argue that the British were the
aggressors and that are and the British
were were stopping U.S vessels on the
sea on uh on the high seas kidnapping
people and forcing them into servitude
of the crown so they were forced to
fight you could argue but were they
justified in their fight
even after that the US is like okay
we're writing this letter to the king
I'm done with this and it's like bro
they've been kidnapping people from
boats and you're writing a letter it was
pretty measured but we got we got
breaking news I don't even know how to
address the daily wire has uploaded a
video our office offer to Stephen
Crowder I guess I officially I love
Jeremy border confirming that uh
officially confirming that daily wire is
who Stephen Crowder was talking about
they put this up a couple minutes ago
it's 52 minutes long we literally could
not just play the video and watch it
during live show but uh but I mean
that's it is what it is I mean that's it
what did the comments say because that's
usually how I get uh you know by looking
at this we'll play some of that I don't
know if I can just show YouTube comments
well we can play it for two minutes
maybe let's play it for a couple minutes
just launch a new initiative call start
over all right
our friend Stephen Crowder has launched
a new initiative called stop big con and
in the video announcing the launch of
the project he talked about leaving the
Blaze and all the different offers that
he filled it from other conservative
organizations and what he thought were
the real problems with those offers and
that's led a lot of people to speculate
about whether or not the daily wire is
one of the people who made him an offer
in particular are we the ones who made
the offer that he put up on the screen
and talked about
um at length and the answer is yes that
offer did come from the daily wire I'm
not trying to hide that fact I'm not
ashamed of that fact in fact I think
it's a very good offer but I think
there's a lot of
sort of misconceptions about the nature
of the offer the nature of the points I
think Stephen misunderstood a lot of the
points and so the way we do here at the
daily wire we're just going to be
incredibly transparent you know that we
like to have our members be a part of
the journey we live stream all of our
company town halls for example we just
find that you know sunlight sometimes is
is the best disinfectant and so with
that in mind I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about how we came to be in
conversations with Stephen how those
conversations ended and and walk you
just line by line through what the
actual document that we sent well so
I'll skip that a little bit we'll only
watch a little bit but I'll jump right
to where we can see he's addressing the
contract and we'll look at a few of his
points you know in order to properly
address this breaking story we have to
have watched the hour-long video in
advance like with Crowder's video we
don't have the luxury because we're live
now and it's happening but let's play a
little bit and see what he says wood and
so we anticipated that and we said
Crowder will bear the burden of
production including all costs
associated therewith on all the content
contemplated herein except on the
quarterly and annual content
contemplated below we'll we'll get to
that part a little bit later it's kind
of a novel concept the quality of the
production will be as good as or better
and is currently existing content
50 million dollars for the initial term
plus 25 million for the renewal term if
extended so that's 50 million dollars
over four years so they were offering
him that's 12.5 million dollars per year
I don't think it's enough guys because
with inflation the amount of
monetization Stephen has potential you'd
have to offer level three two to three
times that I mean maybe not three times
that I mean
here's my you know third party statement
to both Stephen crowd of the daily wire
daily wire you didn't offer enough money
maybe you couldn't afford to Stephen if
you launch your own company you'll make
10 times that
so I I wonder if that's the issue like
Stephen looks at this and he's like 50
million dollars over four years is not
worth it yeah because you got to
understand that's got to pay his
employees if you could send that and
cost and overheads and lawyers and legal
fees
share the burden of production it says
right there then there's taxes and taxes
he's getting 600 Grand a month bear the
bear the bear the cost of uh well theft
it's not because if Crowder's production
costs are 600 000 a month then he's only
profiting 400 and that he's paying 150
in taxes right
taxes are a wild thing dude yeah so uh
that was right there I mean that that's
kind of there we go we now know what the
fee is so the question is Man four years
that's heavy what wasn't the total like
200 million or something we said
yesterday what was the total yeah we
ended up talking about I mean
hyperinflation that's going to be
nothing
I'm gonna have to adjust this for
inflation over the period in order for
account track like that the real
inflation not the fake inflation
government numbers that are actually
fully correct look I know Jeremy boring
I think he's a good dude
um we've talked about potential things
we could work on in deals we could do
and
um you know a lot of people were
speculating back when we went and
visited the daily wire in Nashville we
did that week-long thing they were like
oh Tim's gonna sign with the daily wire
it's like no I don't think there was
ever a possibility that we would be a
daily wire thing it was more like I'll
tell you guys straight up objective
what's going on we have uh every every
different way we distribute content is
is monetized in different ways through
different you know Partners some people
specialize in ads only for podcasts some
people specialize in ads only for
YouTube and so you know uh for instance
our podcast side of things like iTunes
Spotify I'm an expert in those spaces
I'm I know YouTube much better and so we
have third parties that work with us so
I've talked to them like hey can you
guys help us with this because we know
we're not doing a good job that's kind
of stuff we've talked about and being
able to go to a company like the daily
life fire
and literally talk with their CEO and
have him just be very candid and like
the I got to tell you like of all the
business meetings I've had the easiest
one was with the daily wire because it
ultimately ended like okay well you know
maybe we can't work on this now but
we'll figure something out we'll hang
out sometime good good hearing from you
man I've worked with with the first
contract I was ever offered was from uh
well I'll leave I'll leave I'll leave it
I'll leave them out of it it was a big
agency it was one of the big big talent
agencies they represent people you've
heard of on Fox News and they give me
like a 70 page book contract to read and
I'm looking at my and I'm like this is a
joke right and it's like no no don't
worry it's standard and I'm like dude
you come to a guy who's like an
up-and-comer coming a camera in the
space it was a five-year contract I know
I know the game they were playing it was
going to lock up everything it was going
to own me for five years and leave me
with nothing and I couldn't afford to
hire a lawyer to read that many pages so
I threw it in the trash and said have a
nice day not interested in wasting my
time that is almost every negotiation
with every company I've done the daily
wire was was like literally I sat down
with with Jeremy and we talked about how
could we how we could do things and I
thought it went went well that being
said these contracts don't work it says
like right here you can see right here
Crowder will deliver a 1.5 hour long
ladderworth crowd or audio show of
equality and the kind of blah blah blah
they have to say that because they don't
want to sign a deal with you and then
have you drop the quality to save money
but then all of a sudden if you're
someone like Crowder and you're like you
want to own what you want to own
everything and they're like I'm not
going to give you 12 million dollars per
year without the right to distribute the
content to make money on it you just
can't do these deals man yeah these are
old archaic contracts that don't make
sense Ian made that point yesterday and
it was a very good point my question is
how many eggs were the daily wire uh
Team are going to be paying Crowder with
is that in the contract as well because
that's the commodity that I think is an
important one during these very
difficult in inflationary uh times let
me play a little bit more Clay Bennett
uh Blaze well he would still do that
same kind of concept 30 minutes of the
show would now be behind our paywall uh
Crowder can bank or pre-record a limited
number of episodes upon our approval and
reasonable discretion
um days without new original episodes
will be scheduled in advance subject to
our reasonable approval what's this
about probably I like Crowder
you know in addition to his four weeks I
think I think I think the daily wire
should just publish a link to the
contract yeah for sure because he's
already shown and he's going through a
whole bunch of stuff and I think Crowder
opened the door when Crowder showed that
portion he actually said you know don't
make me bring the receipts right so the
daily y responds with okay let's go
through some of the contract at this
point I'm like okay dude just like
publish it yeah what are yours because
like the fee being released is huge
um
here's what here's here's what I think I
think Stephen Crowder
man here's here's the challenge Joe
Rogan's deal what did it turn out to be
like that was initially reported as 100
million and then it was revealed later
200 million we don't know how many years
that's over or what it does include is
it stock or things like that I think I I
don't know or is it the old episodes too
or is it the entire podcast is it the
first episode
that's a lot yeah it got them off the
pro like Joe Rogan had the number one
spot on iTunes the premier podcast
platform and he sold that that makes
sense you know Spotify says look we're
gonna give you 200 million dollars over
X years I don't know how many years it
was I'd imagine it wasn't four but it
could have been and so you imagine Joe's
then getting 50 million bucks a year for
his show that's the crazy thing Stephen
Crowder's show is he's not Joe Rogan but
I mean come on like 12.5 per year 50
million over four years he's he's not a
quarter of Joe Rogan he's half or more
and considering what we're talking about
arguably comparable Joe Rogan reaches a
certain kind of audience and he's huge
we get it but Stephen Crowder motivates
people more I'd be willing to bet that a
Crowder ad read will sell 10 times more
than a Rogan ad read no no offense to
Rogan but Crowder's a culture
crowd is a culture Warrior you know when
he goes out and he says guys you gotta
get this thing because these are the
companies that Believe in Us people are
going to be like yes when Joe Rogan says
I shave my balls here's the thing I use
some people are going to do that's cool
I'm like on it I like on and on his uh
flashlight that he was supporting
looking at it from daily wires
perspective they're putting 50 million
down they want to make profit on this
too so they're anticipating yes it's
worth at least 50 million and then
probably at least 50 on top of that you
know and that's where you know
ballparking like I I agree with you I
think what you know being independent in
this space is the best way to do it I
think it's the best and environment for
a true creative I think it's the best
upside on the profitability and there's
so many business opportunities being
created in this sector which is
relatively new really has just blossomed
in the last two to three years so you
know Crowder might be looking at okay
what am I looking at the next two or
three years but he's gonna be doing this
for 30 40 years potentially if he wants
to here here's here's here's the thing
about any of these deals
a couple years ago we had one of the big
networks come to us and say let's do a
deal and we were much we were relatively
smaller but you know we haven't grown
that much like we've grown a lot but you
know in terms of Revenue and stuff where
as a company we're doing a lot better
but they basically all say like we'll
own it everything you do we own and I'm
just like not interested because I'm
gonna do a three-year deal with you
right that's what you're asking you're
at you're coming to me saying three
years and at the end of it you walk away
you keep your brand you keep your name
we keep everything else I'm not
interested in doing that I already have
I already have my own channels I already
have my own brand I already already have
a membership platform why would I just
give that to you in exchange for what
comparable amounts of money that's a
stupid thing as you said Rogan it's like
a new uh a new entertainment environment
it's a new business model opportunity so
many different ways to make money in the
space that and now the parasites have
come out is well not I'm not calling
anyone particular I'm just saying the
parasitic nature of business has aroused
it happened in 2006 I was doing internet
YouTube videos and like once I got like
10 000 no no like once I started getting
like it's a thousand fifteen hundred
views per video I started getting emails
and messages hey we can we can get take
your channel to the next level hey hey
hey hey hey hey I want to make some
money off you hey say this thing I want
you to say and like let me
I want to play this clip I think he
talks about the fee here this is the
most important part now here's this
section that I know Steven was very
offended by
um and I think he I think he
misunderstood and therefore
misrepresented C reductions
there's a different fee reduction for
all those kinds of contents we've
created daily content if he fails for
any reason to deliver 192 episodes of
The Daily Show
or if he fails to include the ads that
we agreed to or the promotions that we
agreed to in those episodes then we'll
give a hundred thousand dollar reduction
every time what's that about well again
you can't pay someone
any amount of money but you certainly
can't pay them
an unimaginably huge amount of money for
their show and then not get the show so
what this is saying is you don't have to
produce a show every day you don't have
to produce 260 or 250 or 240 or 230 or
220 or 210 episodes a year you got to
produce 192 episodes a year you can film
some of them in advance you can stack
them up all of that's contemplated in
there you could shoot on a Friday so
that you could take two days off next
week
but if you don't give us 192 episodes we
we can't pay you the same amount of
money as if you did give us so hold on
there a minute
if it's 12.5 per year with 192 episodes
that's 65 000 per episode not a hundred
and so the fee is bigger than the fees
per Revenue which which is a weird
payment structure so that that seems
kind of uh uh punishing it you you would
typically want to do a payment structure
that's more you know affirmative like
hey after every 10 episodes we will pay
you blank so you kind of truncate it
into smaller it sounds like they're
doing such a big Advance if you're doing
if you're right if you're doing a
guarantee of x per year I understand
what the daily wire is trying to do but
I will push back and say
what the contract should say and they
could be doing the big ask it could be a
trump move where they don't want Crowder
to negotiate a net benefit they want to
break even so they say 100K expecting
Crowder to come back and say no no Pro
rate divided by the fee for the year so
it should say in my opinion that's how I
do the code I'd say uh what are we
paying you 12-5 a year 192 episodes okay
um any episode you miss we deduct one
unit division into that fee so whatever
that breaks down to 65 000 you miss an
episode or you miss an ad read we will
we will remove 65 from your from your
your minimum your guarantee basically we
are buying 192 episodes for 12. 12.5 per
year if you don't deliver one we prorate
you but the argument is it's the it's
the the library itself is worth more
than the sum of the parts so the one
show by itself then you have 20 shows
all they're worth more than 120th each
because they create you know so I can
see why let's update well we'll let uh
Jeremy continue because I want to cut
him off if he's going to make important
context to part of the conversation 192
episodes so this is just yeah you give
us 192
times 4 minus 1 then out of your 50
million we're hitting minus 100 000.
Stephen said that it's not fair that he
he said 192 times 4 minus one then we're
taking 100 150 million yeah yeah look
man
that doesn't add up yeah it's 50 million
192. it's going to be 65 104. yeah
because you know basically what it
breaks down to so that doesn't quite
quite add up
um that being said the daily wire
offering a steep fee as a means to say
like don't drop shows I also understand
they don't want to do a deal or make a
guarantee and then one day Crowder says
well you know I don't lose anything if I
back out on this deal right if if if he
and I do a deal and then Ian's relying
on me to make a profit
and there's no penalty other than I
don't get paid for the day but Ian gets
screwed over well that's going to suck
so again I think it may be reasonable to
say something like 70 000. so you will
get a 5 000 hit on your overall minimum
because we don't want to create an
opportunity for you to just be like I
guess I'm not going to do a show today
because I don't feel like it you know
what I mean you know what I think
they're factoring into that is their
costs for their production and their
licensing and distributions at 100 so 65
is for Crowder 35 is probably what they
estimate that's actually a really good
point that's actually a really fair
point uh in order to distribute and make
money off of what they're buying from
Crowder they're going to have their own
crew doing all of this stuff as well
editing right uh and and that means if
they've got 300 employees and they've
got you know 10 allocated to proper
promotion distribution making Clips
uploading the website monitoring for
bugs doing the back end stuff because
they're a lot bigger
maybe maybe 100 does make sense I mean I
certainly think uh it you factor that in
and you factor their loss of profits in
so they're basically saying we're paying
you 65. we're also going to lose 10
because we can't do our sales our
employees showed up to work our
employees showed up also the people who
bought the ads are going to come to us
angry so that's actually an interesting
point Fair Point you know I don't think
we can go through this whole thing
though so I don't know if there's any
other I'm going to do it later it's a
tough deal you know what I I I I'm very
curious to see what Crowder says if
there's anything else but to me this
just seems like business tough business
uh it's a lot of money there's there's
high stakes and people want to make sure
that their Investments are protected so
I'm not necessarily anti-dilly wire on
this but
um I I am curious I'm sure there's just
a 50 minute video Crowders got his whole
you know experience going through this
so there's a lot more to this I'm sure
this is actually really awesome that
this transparency is incredible right
it's so good for the business
environment I mean the the here's a
challenge for the daily wire a lot of
people are saying like you should have
said anything he didn't mention you bro
everybody was saying it was the daily
Wire yeah and and that and then now the
daily wire has no opportunity to us no
they they they're basically have no
choice and hey it's good promotion but
Crowder was talking about how not
necessarily these figures wasn't it that
they uh were like partnering with the
bad guys or something well his complaint
was that uh let me see if I can actually
find the part where he he'll talk about
it I imagine he said the big con and
that they're working with uh Big Texas
here we go
look if Crowder is boycotted if Crowder
is boycotted or dropped by more than 50
percent of his then extant advertising
partners that is
if 50 of the money that he's making from
advertisers is suddenly gone and we're
not able to replace that Revenue within
90 days
then his fee will be reduced by 25 until
such time as the ad Revenue has been
restored for a period whoa that is
giving Crowder free money that's insane
think about that for two seconds if
Crowder's revenue is dropped by 50 50
from his advertising Partners plural
moving on if it's dropped by more than
50 percent of his then advertising
Partners they will reduce his fee by
only 25 which is what 250 000 a year-ish
well potentially so it's potentially
advertising Insurance it sounds like but
50 of his Revenue may not necessarily
equate to his fee so this is right right
making more than 250 000 a year in
address what does AD Revenue compared to
the fee you know 25 percent of I see it
so so it it could be they don't include
membership Partners but they're also
giving them 90 days meaning if if
something happens that's a nice grace
period three months to figure it out
that means Crowder could be making half
the revenue for three months and they
still won't charge him a fee or a
penalty what I don't like will floats
it makes him rely on advertisers still
which is I think he's trying to get away
from that being reliant on advertisers
and if if his contract forces him if if
I was going to do a deal with someone I
would say if your content gets boycotted
your fee will be reduced commensurate to
the amount of money lost from those
boycotts like and that's the crazy thing
like
we share the risk well or yeah I mean we
can give you a guarantee but if there's
no money coming in like there's no
guarant there's no money to guarantee
you that is to me like a little bit of a
float daily wire you know they're
they're almost a creditor in that
instance I that that that came off as
like
a a surprisingly gracious I didn't ex
here we go here's the important part I
didn't expect the daily wire to offer
something like that to be honest part or
not and then we lose the business as a
result and now no one pays Stephen
anything and no one releases Steven's
content he has to go build it all from
scratch in crisis
ban the Crowder content cannot be
released on any of the major platforms
because of its content being banned from
those platforms
then we'll reduce the fee of YouTube 20
if Apple 20 if Facebook 10 is Spotify
10. same kind of concept
if the content simply cannot appear and
therefore cannot not only be used for
marketing cannot be used to grow the
brand also can't be monetized or we
can't pay them the same as if it was if
you're making 25 of your money on
YouTube
uh and now YouTube is permanently gone
we you can't make that money anymore
it's not punishment this is really what
it comes down to Steven's you can pay
them philosophy seems you just would run
it at a loss if you did you can though I
deserve to be paid millions and millions
and millions of dollars
whether my show drives the revenue or
not
I got I gotta pause right there and say
Jeremy yeah that's the point the reason
Stephen Crowder wants to do do a deal
with you is so that you assume the risk
and he doesn't the the only and that's
why I'm saying these contracts don't
make sense because what Jeremy is saying
makes sense from Jeremy's perspective
but it doesn't make sense from from the
perspective of anybody who wants to do a
deal it's it would be like
it would be like someone saying you know
Luke I'm gonna buy your RV off you
and then if it breaks you I'm not giving
you the money
like well well hold on I always break my
point is my vehicle put it in the
contract Crowder's basically saying like
I don't want to worry about this I don't
want to worry about the risk the revenue
you figure it out and then Jeremy says
okay but if it breaks we're not going to
pay you I mean I think that's reasonable
if you buy it or you don't if Stephen is
wants to offload the risk then he's
offloading a huge chunk of the income I
mean that's the risk is a big part of
why he's worth so much is because it's
on his shoulders the deal can't exist
this is what I was saying like when I
said Crowder was right about everything
with these contracts like and and I like
the daily wire guys I think Jeremy's a
good dude and I think Jeremy is doing
right as a business but it doesn't make
sense for Crowder to sell
what he has
to basically hear you're in the exact
same position we don't assume the same
level of risk like you're you're gonna
you're gonna face the same risks you're
if you get a strike you don't get paid I
do think there's some guarantees like
I'll point this out
if he gets banned by YouTube the only
dock his fee by twenty percent
that that's actually
I mean that that structure right there I
think is actually really great
that's that that is the daily wire is
doing some good things YouTube
is a larger portion of Revenue and
viewership so when it comes to direct
sponsorships you'll make more of a
YouTube read than a than a than a
podcast read to a certain extent but
podcasts in the long run will make more
money it's it's it's hard to explain
like
you get more views on YouTube so you can
sell a package for more
equal to the number of views though the
cpms are lower so for them to break it
down this way actually seems like there
is some stuff being taken off Crowder's
shoulder in terms of uh I wonder what
his angle is when he says you know
they're basically partnering with big
Tech to take this is it yeah and so he
gets stopped he gets he gets he gets
penalized if he breaks YouTube's rules
but is he thinking that like daily wire
is gonna like sabotage him so that they
just may are able to pay Crowder less
like it he seemed very angry about it
I'm just wondering what in it to me this
doesn't strike me as this is them
partnering up with big Tech to take time
yeah he was kind of he was kind of
alluding to that we definitely need more
clarification for because let's be
honest here uh you know the daily wire
and Ben Shapiro do get suggested a lot
on Facebook if you look at the most uh
shared links from Facebook it's usually
the daily wire and a lot of people are
asking that's kind of it's kind of weird
you know that's kind of you know what's
going on here and then we have these
statements by Crowder so you know
there's obviously a lot more questions
here Zuckerberg's a huge conservative
turns out I don't know nah I I have far
more questions than answers this stuff
you know working in Hollywood contracts
uh there's no there's no market Standard
you know especially in this burgeoning
industry so it's really fascinating to
see a little bit of the inside
information because now you can say all
right I'm this x percent compared to
Crowder he was getting it gives you a
chance to but people are making this up
as we go you know what what is a Marcus
Center for a contract it's all black box
in Hollywood dude I I I know everybody
is about people commenting in the on
that video saying I stand with Stephen
Crowder and uh
I just feel so bad for the daily wire
because they're not bad people and
they're trying really hard they're not
this like the hardest of culture
Warriors like we or Crowder are but I
don't think they're bad guys who are
doing bad things I think Candace is hard
culture culture Warrior like you and
Chris that's true that's a fair point
but Jeremy's he's all big I mean he's
not all businesses in the business
and what is a woman was extremely
important that was tremendously powerful
and very important thing but when you
say daily wire you got to talk who owns
daily wire it's it's Jeremy Ben you know
and Jeremy's in the business aspect he's
not a culture Warrior but I want to
clarify when I said I feel bad for him I
don't feel bad necessarily about this
like dude you offer a big name a
contract that pisses him off don't be
surprised if they come and they get mad
at you about it and they can wag around
and be like this is a terrible contract
I feel bad because how do you compete
with the likes of Disney
how do you do it yeah it's like Disney
will get people to sign up no matter
what because they own Flubber because
they own
Decades of American cultural history and
the daily wires got to build it and it's
probably just 10 times harder than
managing Disney
I mean look at look at what they're
doing with all the Marvel stuff
regurgitated remakes
etc etc and the daily wire has to
navigate the space and you want the
worst possible thing is
what made what was the big hit for the
daily Wire yeah what is a woman that
Matt Walsh documentary and what about
Gina carano's film
I didn't see her on the Prairie yeah so
the issue is the daily wire is trying to
break the cultural mold take the space
and to an extent it's working I mean
they have a million paying monthly
members so they're building it up
they're what 20 times smaller than
Netflix is but did we hear about how
tremendously amazing Tara on the Prairie
was did we see groundbreaking virality
no but what his woman did the problem is
what is a woman is political that means
the daily wire is still trapped in their
pigeonhole and if they're going to have
the cultural impact that we actually
need them to have they need to get
bigger hits in different areas that are
very very difficult to do they need
their own Mickey Mouse I will say just
looking at that contract assuming that's
the primary contract that's a very
simple like simplified contract they get
far more verbose far more carve outs and
exceptions and preconditions so uh again
I'm not taking a side on this because I
don't have enough information
um I I'm definitely very curious to hear
what Crowder's perspective is someone a
super chatted remember Crowder is
bringing in 300 000 Subs at 10 bucks a
month that's 36 million a year Crowder
uh let me see sorry let me kind of
scroll Crowder wants band protection and
is wanting a distribution partner I I
agree I don't I don't know that we can
guarantee Crowder will bring in 300 000
I think it's possible more than that I
think from a contract perspective if if
someone came to me and said look you do
it you know if like Ian came to me and
said bring me on the show and I
guarantee you ten thousand new paying
monthly members I'd be like you can't
guarantee me that
like I can look at your metrics and then
make and then make a bet and if I'm
wrong I lose a lot of money I don't know
if I'd want to do that yeah there would
have to be some cash incentive if I was
going to guarantee a subscriber buy
something I also do think from a
practical standpoint Stephen Crowder
likely will bring in 300 000 to 500 000
new paying monthly members at 10 bucks a
month in which case uh
yeah this contract's not good you made
an interesting observation that he might
be concerned that with the 20 if he gets
banned off YouTube 20 if you could spend
that if daily wire is in charge of the
edit and the the post that they could
put something up they would put him in a
light that would get him banned and then
be able to cut his salary by 20. he's
very nervous about their affiliation
with big tech and and that to me has not
been addressed in this we saw the
provision but it to me it doesn't really
where where's Crowder getting he was
very upset very uh nervous about I I I I
don't see it yet I don't know what he's
focused on crowder needs to do his own
thing
because like I said the other day I
think Crowder would make 10 million
bucks a month people are saying 36
million a year I disagree uh based on
how big Crowder is based on what he was
able to do with rumble on uh on with the
midterms
they had 10 no he had like uh what he
had like seven or eight times the amount
of viewers we had yeah so like I think
we I think we ended up with I don't
remember we had 60 70 000 he had 500 000
on Rumble special shout out to Dave
Landau that that
that lovable little lovable garden gnome
I love you brother I love you man he's
so awesome dude I think Crowder should
launch his independent mug Club
and uh 10 bucks a month honestly it
might need to be a little bit more than
that because because of costs these days
like no seriously like bandwidth costs
especially if you're gonna do anything
live but 10 bucks a month probably
probably would work
I think you'd probably get between 300
500K
probably making five million a month
with no ads yeah none just off subs yeah
yeah back-end hosting is expensive these
are the numbers that the contract should
be working out we're going to cover
hosting like we mentioned that last
night like do Tech contracts with these
with these actors these performers so
that you cover their back end
expenditure and costs I I I I'm I'm
doing the math in my head right now I
think 300K is a good estimate it's a
good estimate so what needs to happen in
this contract is Crowder should probably
say here's here's what I would do I go
through all of it and I would say oh you
want all these things my answer to you
is yes and we're going to add one
paragraph I get 80 of memberships
and then they're going to go oh well I
don't know about that and I'll be like
okay here's what I'll do I'll take 100
of my memberships and I'll make my
website thanks for your time yeah right
which I don't know why it doesn't just
do that I mean they have a massive
distribution platform well it's because
he's also been like demonetized on
YouTube for like how many years now
here's been on for I don't know here's
where's what I can say career around
three years if I I I I know this to be
true
that if we did some kind of partnership
with the daily wire this show would be
10 times bigger in half the time we
would have like there there the daily
wires I think 20 times bigger than we
are they have people all over the place
they have more fans than we do they have
more connections more celebrities who
visit their offices they have their own
Talent roster if I did do a deal with
them in any capacity and they were able
to be like here we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna change your show
it would just like bigger studio built
by a more professional company faster oh
they got The Swinging cameras that come
through right like we're we're a company
here at timcast and we are every day
trying to learn
and and navigate and and Forge this path
forward meaning like oh man we had we
have hiccups all day every day and it's
just like constant headaches and I
talked to Jeremy periodically and then
he's like he's like well my friend just
just know that always gets worse and I'm
laughing I'm like he's right because I'm
like you know we're we're working on a
project right now with the daily wire
crew a music project I don't want to say
too much about we're really excited and
uh so I've been talking to him and then
you know I'll mention like oh we had
this problem with this financial thing
and then he laughs like I remember we
had that yeah not 20 times worse and so
I'm just like if if we were able to get
a company like them to like just even
consult it would be huge if we were able
to have their resources in terms of
booking
be massive we would have bigger
celebrities bigger names bigger
connections yeah in no time but you know
look we're our own company we do our own
thing and there's there's it's
impossible to just you can't just make
something like that happen same thing as
true with Crowder why would Crowder do a
deal with with daily wire it's like
you're saying their production resources
distribution and access is so massive
that it it would substantially benefit
Crowder however
as for who Crowder is he doesn't need
them
he can make his own website it will just
be harder it will take longer but he
will make substantially more money
yeah even Rush Limbaugh worked for
another company what Company Salem media
I believe the whole his whole career uh
at least at the end I believe I'm just
jumping on that but like I mean Candace
Owens one of the biggest names and you
know she's generally worked with Prager
and and turning point and now daily wire
I mean it's just it's just different
business paths and it's just it it how
how your lifestyle meshes with that how
you're you know kind of vision and your
creativity I personally I can't work for
anyone I I would rather take less money
and just if I'm not going to work that
day I'm not going to work that day you
know like that's on me but if someone's
telling me hey you got to do this you
gotta [ __ ] I can't do it at this point
so yeah I'm the same way like why take
orders from somebody it just doesn't
make sense I've been through that at
this stage I'm working at for Tim the
Tim cast Corporation and it's like it's
a little emasculating at times like I'm
like damn I can't just
promote I can't just publish a new show
like it's owned by Tim cast corporation
which is reasonable I think because of
work I'm getting paid by TPS Corporation
and I can always end the contract you
know but like but I think there's a time
place because the social capital gaining
outweighs the value of anything I could
do on my own at this stage of my career
but but Ian that's technically not true
it's it's true in the sense that anybody
who works for timcast has an agreement
that anything you make related to our
business we own that means what do we do
here we do political commentary we do
YouTube videos we do social media posts
we make music
we're making video games now and you
recognize that we're doing all of this
multimedia stuff
however it also states that at any point
you want to do something you need only
tell us
that's it true yeah yeah that's in there
that's in contract also so like the
point is we can't have people work here
who are going to be like I'm going to
make music for you and then we go
awesome and then they come out with an
album it goes up a platinum or whatever
and they're like well I made that at
home I think because of it we'll do we
hired you to make that standard
Hollywood procedure yeah that deals with
major Studios like I can't say them but
uh they basically have first look they
own any movie you make subsequent if
you're like the if you're a first time
director for a major Studio they own
your ass because like we kind of brought
you up on the map and I'm not saying
that but like uh and but you know I will
say about Jeremy boring and Ben Shapiro
they don't work for anyone you know they
started that company and just built it
up I think you guys are outside looking
in you guys are crushing it also so
first look is a good way to put it the
way I describe it everybody is
everybody has to have an agreement that
if you're working here you're working
for us however I don't want to own your
music man I don't want to own your book
because of our our contracts with other
companies you just have to come to us
and be like I'm going to write this book
it's nothing to do with you it's me I'll
be like okay yeah all right I'll write
up contract saying we have no rights
over the book They're produced by
Russell you're good but there's
something in the back of the ma of my
artist's mind where it's just knowing
that I have a contract signed that is
owns my work in the until I override it
is there it's like it's messes with me
but I have to weigh the value like the
value of to be honest I would do the
show for free anyway like I you know
I've even talked with you about like I
don't need the money I'm not here for
the money I don't care about the social
capital far outweighs the dollars in my
opinion
um so I'm constantly doing the weight of
like everyone's getting about your
contract decision you know what's best
for your life and what you want to do I
I I remember thinking when I was younger
I was like oh you know I'm going to
start a business and I'm going to scale
it up and then it's going to be a multi
whatever I don't even want to do that
you know quality of life I I I don't
think of how many had it you know do you
really just want to be consumed by your
business all day every day I actually
want some time to hang out with my wife
and you know future kids so it's also
like I don't want to work all day every
day I don't want to compete with them
you break my voice like me and Tim both
make cartoon like we were funny act we
do acting and stuff like I don't want to
compete I'd rather work together I don't
want to compete with Jeremy I don't want
to compete with Steve Crowder I want to
work you know unified you know kind of
create art together like we don't have
any kind of contract anywhere near the
level of what the what the daily wire is
offering like the that massive lighting
out terms or like whatever like we don't
have anything there's no time period on
the contract there's literally nothing
in any agreement anywhere that's like
Ian if you get as banned we're going to
dock your past like no hey anyway you
know like get mad about it I suppose but
also it's like there's no uh no time
commitment which is Ultimate in this
rapidly changing entertainment
structured environment like putting
someone on a three-year freaking leash
is insane in my opinion well there's a
reason for that and it's what we were
talking about the other day right so we
have no no term uh contracts with
anybody who works here and that's a huge
risk on our end because I'm you know I
joked everybody I'm a communist so it's
like
if if we invest in you as a as a
personality and then you quit on us
we've just lost all of our investment
you know and that's why nobody wants to
do that that's a reasonable position
though that's again that's standard in
Hollywood that's like a computer we have
we don't have a term for anybody like
Ian could leave the show whatever he
wants to make his own thing that's like
the yeah right now quite generous the
robot brain is if I were to lock you in
then I will benefit in the future but
the reality is I love you more as a
human for respecting me and my freedom
and and I would gladly hang out with you
I'll tell you I think I'm better at
business than all these people if you
don't want to be here you should not be
here and I do not want to keep sinking
money into a person who's trying to
leave yeah now that's wasted money so
all these these big companies they're
like look if I'm gonna invest 10 million
dollars in you I need to know that I can
monetize that for four years or whatever
make money of it my attitude is hey look
I'm gonna invest a couple hundred grand
into you and the stuff you're building
and if at any point you don't want to be
here it's probably better you just leave
because I don't want to waste any more
money
like if you don't want to be here
what so like what what am I supposed to
do with that you're going to be unhappy
I think it's a better structure overall
like again Hollywood it's cold in in
dehumanized because it's just a massive
Mega publicly traded Corporation dealing
with a bunch of creative idiots
very successful people sometimes but I
mean yeah you when you have a more like
a family-owned business you don't need
this super restrictive contract you have
leadership you have friendship you have
you know you can do things on a
handshake a contract is just in case the
worst happens you should be able to just
work things out do you think that
someone chatted Tim wants to volunteers
not hostages no that that yes I worked
for fusion and they had me under
contract then they went woke and I said
I'd like to leave and they said no
here's more money and I said this sucks
do you think that it's because it
doesn't scale like these kind of these
family-run smaller contracts they're
like I trust you let's let's work
together they don't scale because you
the owner loses contact with the new
hires because just because there's so
many employees yes I mean obviously as
you get bigger you're going to lose that
more personalized connection with your
employees and you know so it again it's
there's no one right way to do this in
in any way shape or form any of these
powerful voices you guys anyone else
it's do what you think feels right and I
think what It ultimately comes down to
what we're all doing this for is to help
save this country and save this planet
from tyranny and and this stuff is all
kind of on the side yeah straight up man
okay let's go we're gonna go super jets
we're gonna go to Super Chat so smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have that members only
uncensored show coming up for you and we
got a bunch of really crazy stuff to
talk about uh we we do I just put it
that way I don't know because it's like
been built it's been building up because
I haven't been able to do my morning
show and uh technically I shouldn't even
be doing this show but I'm not going to
cancel on people just because like my
voice is [ __ ] up that was a thing
that's like if you cancel your day shows
and just do this show then you we won't
ever have to look for news because you
already have it and you'll be chomping
at the bit to talk about it anyway
well so it's like
I probably should not do anything just
sleep because I don't know what was
wrong with my voice to be really honest
uh you know I'm sure dehydration maybe
too much salt maybe but I've been doing
everything people like garble honey and
it's like dude come on man fasting
everything fasting will help yeah it
didn't work like 12 hours of no food it
did it really maybe after three days in
a row I think it's just something that
happens
yes it could just be overused for just
speaking for a while eventually it's
gonna just and then instead of taking a
day off I ended up doing the show right
last night and but to be fair like I'm
raspy but it's nowhere near as bad as it
was on Friday you know so I'm assuming
I'll be able to work tomorrow
we'll read some super chats and you know
thank you guys for being members at
timcast.com because it's basically
afforded me the ability to take the
mornings off which is extremely like I
get really angry because like I come in
here I do all the work and then I start
doing warm-ups exercises I took
ibuprofen because it reduces swelling to
help you talk and I recorded again for
four minutes and I was complaining about
Greta tunberg and then I just was like
pushing harder and harder to get on my
I'm done and I got pissed but if we
didn't have the website I'd be freaking
out because I'd be like how do I pay
people the membership's life man I bet a
lot of people are thinking that way what
if what if YouTube turns on me what if I
don't follow their rules my entire
career but like my concern is if we
didn't have the website memberships it'd
be more like if I don't do this work
today how do I pay the salaries of the
people who are working here that's
that's the that's the problem but the
website you guys as members like you
know you give me a sick day let's read
some news
all right
what does it say uh C.D Stein says hey
Tim breaking news of prison in Hillsboro
Illinois has had at least 15 guards
taken to hospitals in serious condition
due to fentanyl exposure
wow man wow Laura Spade says Bank bail
bail-ins bail-ins are starting the FDIC
was having a talk about this recently
oh I looked up the uh the Bank of
America crisis it looks like it was
something went wrong with a glitch with
Zell which is the transfer service that
a bunch of these Banks own Zell is weird
it's almost like antitrust in a way
because all it's like Bank of America
Wells Fargo Chase Bank all these Banks
own this this thing together and they
all transfer money on this thing I've
always wondered about this it's very PNC
Bank also JPMorgan Chase Capital One
Capital One yeah it's weird it's a weird
weird weird thing it's owned by early
warning Services of the company that
owns Zell and early warning Services is
owned by all those Banks right isn't
that odd waffle Sensei says if Luke
really loved us he would stay but he
doesn't so he's leaving I hate you I say
we all go and buy out his T-shirt
inventory so he completely runs out of
stock please we are please don't do that
please don't go to
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and buy all
the shirts up I will have no other
shirts
I'll go shirtless we got to get shim
sham back did you say you'll go
shirtless if that's a promise
I need everybody to uh tweet at Sheamus
get over here it's time who's that
we should uh when James comes back we
should get like a really massive baked
potato and put like candles in it and
like hand it to him I made a special uh
potato shirt for him on uh for members
of uh Luke uncensored do you guys want
to find some super chats and read it so
I gotta talk as much yeah
I'm tweeting at Sheamus right now anyone
that wants to retweet my tweet to
Sheamus please do it
um
yeah but I don't I can't see them from
here so let me do it from here Luke you
want to grab one I'm looking right next
no I got one right now uh from Josh o
the UK just recently arrested a
Christian for praying silently thought
crimes are now real it wasn't it wasn't
for silent prayer it was for like
loitering or something but they were
silently praying she was staying in
front of abortion clinic or something
yeah and she'd been there day after day
and I think they were like you can't
stand on the road anymore it's loitering
I don't know interesting Gabriel Lopes
has a 50 uh Super Chat saying your voice
will not return to normal it's how Alex
Jones got his years
uh this is a super chat from not that
guy Ian you don't own art brother man
let's make something cool
yeah you don't yeah true you know that's
why Joe that's what big ethos at Minds
that's the whole point of the company is
like don't be too concerned about people
claiming your work like your work you
think it's yours it's just there it's
just you made it just let it be
um
you have the super cats from the very
beginning so you gotta you gotta do that
there's a really funny one from Pirate
Taurus sockenhoff
it says it's called puberty Tim your
body is changing some
you'll notice along with a deeper voice
your beard should start filling in
finally did something drop down there
Tim two somethings oh man that's funny
all right I got one from Lord clamino
this is says you guys are missing things
Crowder said it's the fact that it's the
fact these conditions force people to
abide by Big Tex biased rules they often
enforce arbitrarily that don't encourage
one to actually speak the truth but the
opposite and that I agree in that I
think that you're referring to that they
if he gets banned off YouTube then he
loses money
from his contract so they're kind of
forcing him to abide by YouTube's rules
to uh that's what happens
anyway you know if he was independent he
lost YouTube money so they're kind of
saying well you know we're not YouTube
Insurance necessarily and they might be
YouTube Insurance to an extent if
depending on how much revenue comes in
from YouTube and they only dock them 20
I mean there is probably some give and
take there but uh again we still need to
know more information
I got another one that Tim's highlighted
for me from Linda T saying Tim I'm a
stay-at-home mom of two kids limited
money but I remember because I like that
you were fighting the culture war and I
stand behind you as do I thank you thank
you I really do appreciate it yeah I
mean you know what's really hard is like
I understand why the daily wire does
what they do being the people running
the machine gives you affords you the
ability to fight the culture more
directly me being the host of the
principal show and trying to run the
machine is like damn near impossible
yeah not everyone has it in them to to
do that so yeah uh yeah but Trump has a
20 Super Chat saying how many people pay
for Crowder that don't already pay for
daily wire how many new members would
they really get I doubt it's 300K
it's a good point yeah there's not a
crossover there yeah they're both like
statists yeah
everyone's a status to you because it's
relative you know they're like you know
they're semi-communists both of them
let's be real do we make like the
moderate libertarian Network
thing moderate libertarian that doesn't
go together it doesn't make sense yes it
does you gotta get Super Chat for
anti-statist Alliance here's a good one
this is from the yeti 90. oh do you
wanna no I was gonna say it's it's a
network for people who aren't outright
anarchists but are lean more in that
direction than conservatives or liberals
do you know what I mean so like you'll
get your libertarian you'll get your
Dave Smith's but you'll get some
conservatives who are like Pro 2A
we got another five dollar Super Chat by
Vegas 96 he says DC Drano probably had
the best Twitter account top five in my
opinion
yeah you got it back I got it back uh
I've been rage tweeting all day
um every day it's my favorite thing to
do and as my lawyer said it's no
surprise you ever banned in the first
place did you just get it back like four
weeks ago oh yeah yeah so
um yeah it I've been going you know on a
tear and uh like I said the mo the thing
I'm most proud of is our is our case
that's in the ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals right now uh we had our hearing
like I said I'm represented by harmeet
Dillon who I think is the best civil
rights attorney in modern history and
um you know any day I could wake up and
we're gonna get that decision and we're
almost certainly gonna be appealing to
the Supreme Court and the reason this
case is I believe historic is because
it's the government that is coordinating
with big Tech to censor us I think it's
happening across the entire Spectrum I
mean think of all the Twitter files
we've seen now imagine YouTube Facebook
Instagram uh so I think we've just hit
the tip of the iceberg and I have a lot
of friends in Congress and there's gonna
be a lot of subpoenas going out where I
think the Twitter files are just the tip
of the iceberg we're going to learn a
lot more Saint Matthew has a 20 Super
Chat saying since we are discussing
Ian's contract how much of his
compensation is graphene and uh uh and
psychedelic mushrooms all of it actually
that that little jar right there was all
it took he inside a 20-year contract for
that little vial it was worth it and
I'll sign it again
uh here's a good one from the yeti 90.
says I want a shirt that says quote Luke
help me stop smoking I'm gonna keep
sending this until it gets ready did I
help you quit smoking if I did I'm very
happy because that's something I was
dealing with uh myself uh previously
before a couple years ago and that's a
big thing that's if you know not a lot
of people get to overcome it so if you
really did quit shout out to you and
congratulations for living an addiction
free life and not being controlled by
any statist substance that you are
giving the money to the government
through so maybe make a t-shirt that
says Luke help me stop smoking people or
get rid of the cigarette tax like one
way to quit smoking actually if you
remind yourself I quit smoking one thing
that really made me quit smoking is
understand how much taxes went into the
government with me smoking I was like
what they're getting how much I can't do
this and that was one reason uh that I
just decided to quit too it's just I
don't know it just feels better just to
be able to breathe and not be dependent
on somebody something that I that I was
convinced that I needed when I really
didn't so epic I went through the same
thing with marijuana I thought I
couldn't be sociable with it without it
I was in like 2007 I was I thought oh
this is making me likable and that just
sent me on a downward spiral is me that
was likable that stuff was just there so
Serge I'm only able to see the recent
can you go into the back and get the
earlier ones I got another one here by
John McGee saying Breaking New Zealand
prime minister jackinda Arden announced
resignation good absolutely uh that's
the news that was breaking during this
podcast and she was an awful leader that
implemented a lot of the world economic
Forum policies and essentially destroyed
any form of freedom and liberty in New
Zealand and she was facing a lot of
people opposing her and her popularity
went down because of just how absolutely
horrible she was to her people so good
good written in my opinion search yeah I
got one here from Ian uh ask Rogan about
how he Saved My Life by contacting 9-1-1
from another state went by casual
libtard I believe yeah that that was in
2017. he was on a live stream and he had
a seizure and uh he I think there's like
10 people watching and then a bunch of
people were dming me like dude Ian like
he just he just dropped like what and I
was like I don't know I've never met you
know and and then I checked his live
stream and it was still going and uh we
couldn't and I was like and I posted on
my page I was like yo does anyone know
anything about Ian and someone's like I
think he like lives in this town and
then we like looked it up and then we
like sent cops to his house and he you
know so he ended up being okay but
that's a very that's a blast from the
past yeah man all right another one
really fast Luke
what happened to your thumb man I was
going to ask you the same question
earlier uh they said this person Fleck
has talks as we know notice the bandage
you don't have to say if you're not
comfortable if you don't want to but
um I was moving and then there was like
broken glass and I just like put my hand
into this that's a boring story I know
it's not fun I was trying to think of it
shout out shout out flankers talks one
of my best friends awesome his thumbs
just sore because he loaded 3 000 rounds
of nine millimeter over the weekend
there you go there you go that should
have been a better one got one here from
PJ now I got another one by separ Ives
this one's better he says Ian you've
been rolling more 20s than usual did you
change up your routine diet or anything
did you even lift with look bro question
mark now uh semper don't encourage him
and number two he has not been lifting
has not been working out with me and has
been declining my invites to do personal
training with me correct uh I have been
working out though I've been at least 20
push-ups every day if not 40. I have an
eclipse 40 a day yet and 20 push-ups a
day yeah that's that's bare minimum just
so that my body's ready to lift 30 or 40
pounds I did yoga last night lightly but
a lot of like those got those blocks and
doing those push-ups where you go way
down and like stretch open your chest
just eating a lot of meat like doubling
up on my protein intake tripling up on
my protein are you on that beef liver I
haven't taken any of that yet all Epic
bars right now we got these incredible
epic bars it's like bison meat with
cranberry I mean it's just so pure yeah
so that that has definitely changed
things up maybe it's building my
confidence thank you for noticing keep
Mindy and I do have this note here
saying Ian Bill's muscle is one of your
goals what's happening man it happens
slowly and then all at once I believe
man here's one from PJ says Tim can you
get Annie Jacobson on to talk about her
book first platoon chilling stuff maybe
I don't know what that is Annie Jacobson
I have another one here from sevi Rose
saying most banks do not have a uh did
not have gold to trade for cash after
the Civil War that's a myth and you
should investigate the history of
central banks in this country a little
closer Rogan
that they didn't have enough gold uh it
says that most banks did not have gold
to trade for cash so that wasn't
fungible directly well that that I mean
that's what the Federal Bank people said
that there wasn't enough gold in the
bank runs destabilized but a lot of
these destabilization events were
actually I believe orchestrated to
generate uh enthusiasm and getting that
passed so uh it's it's kind of you know
oh that's what history tells us but as
we've learned today what is being said
right in front of our faces is often not
true so you know I agree to an extent
but uh it's not always what it seems 10
Buck stew has a 50 Super Chat saying Tim
I don't think you're losing your voice I
think you are slowly channeling the
energy of Alex Jones to become his new
vessel soon you'll be selling timcast
vitamins and ranting about the chemicals
and the grip tape turning the skaters
gay
is that true
we're we're making we're turning the
people into skaters oh it's even better
yeah here's one from 10 bucks stew Tim
oh wait you just read that yeah that was
a good one I got another one by Ike uh
kefka says Ian 100 push-ups 100 sit-ups
100 air squats and uh 19 kilometer run
19. I've never run more than like two
miles in a burst have you yeah is that
like from the one punch man thing is
that is that what you're referencing I
don't know if that's that is or not it's
like an animated dude if I could get how
much could you run in a mile like what's
your time in a mile I haven't I haven't
timed it since like high school and it
was nine and a half minutes I I was so
out of shape I didn't we could go for a
run you want to go for it no you saw I
have a gun but he always denies he did
not he doesn't want to I I keep running
I've been I've been very persistent
haven't I you have been yeah and every
time I see her in the kitchen I'm like
Ian we gotta go we gotta do this let's
go dude I want to make a deal with you
I'm gonna get ripped if you get more
optimistic I am optimistic I'm very
optimistic homeschooling and the Second
Amendment and people's Liberties and
freedoms and and Humanity figure out
figure out problems yeah has been very
pushy in a great way as a friend about
me working out and it's keeping it in
the Forefront of my mind so thank you
Luke I'll uh I'll read this one here
Nicole says have you asked Crowder to be
on the show to clarify stop big con
yes
good one moving on
Bridget May shadara says Ian thanks for
representing our age group I'm 48 you're
always rolling 20s for me much love to
you and your family take care you too
Bridget much love to your family man
thanks
hell yeah you want to read that one yeah
I got one from buy Bitcoin daily
parentheses Jake Tim Luke you guys are
missing the point Crowder has been
demonetized for years Crowder would be
in the default the moment he signed the
contract I brought that up too I
mentioned that he's been demonetized for
a long time but I said did it say the
amount of times I said I said band
um because he can still do ad reads I
think it's a I think it's a if he was a
band yeah that was yeah he could make a
video and then be like hey everybody buy
you know
Mary's are not Harry's by uh by whatever
he's indoors Jeremy's razors
Harry's the bad one yeah yeah but he
could just do that you know what I mean
there's interesting things about these
contracts too you got to understand the
dirty games they play they'll be like
you have to they'll say something like
we're gonna give you you know a big
marketing budget we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna help promote your show
you'll be like wow marketing budget
right and they'll say yeah we're gonna
put half a million dollars in marketing
behind your show
and you go okay
and see I'm good at business I'm not you
know I'm not the best at business but
I'm just I'm just not bad and so I go
and where does that where does that
money go
and then they'll say something like oh
well they're stipulations it's not a
marketing budget
you know for like any kind of marketing
what these companies will do is they'll
find ways to like create value marketing
you know that's not you know like
it's it's the the true value of
something is is vague so they can be
like we'll give you a half a million
dollars worth of x
and then they'll just say like oh Ian
this water bottle is worth a hundred
dollars so like a targeted ad read
they'll be like oh it's worth 35 dollars
for a thousand views so also to pay
themselves exactly charge a hundred
thousand dollar marketing fee for
internal fees uh here's our expenses and
they'll probably when it comes to
marketing they recoup it first or
they'll have some of these companies
will have like the guy owns 10 companies
and they'll say oh as part of the
marketing fee we're hiring you know uh
super marketing for a hundred thousand
dollars a year to figure out a plan and
and strategize and you're like uh but
the CEO owns that company Hollywood is
dirty entertainment is a little less
dirty but pretty dirty you absolutely
need a very good lawyer not just a
lawyer you need a top lawyer if you're
going to be doing a serious money deal
you'll be like
oh wow half a million dollars in
marketing and you're thinking yourself I
can get a commercial on Fox News I can
get a commercial in the New York add in
the New York Times I'll get a billboard
in Times Square and they're thinking
themselves we're going to find a d-list
celebrity we're going to offer him the
equivalent of a hundred thousand dollars
to do a shout out but what he'll get an
exchange from us isn't 100 Grand it'll
be a hundred thousand dollars worth of
our time for Consulting our crypto token
or maybe a commercial on our Network so
they'll be like oh this guy charges 100
Grand per shout out so now your bar your
budget's down to 400. then they go to
him and say okay now we're now you're on
the hook for this here's what I do we're
gonna give you 20 hours of our
Consulting so it's just like
it's all paper money they're like Elon
Musk lost more money than anyone else in
the history of the planet no he didn't
no that money didn't exist it was
imaginary that's the people don't get it
there was no money there we got a five
dollar Super Chat from Alex who says if
Luke leaves I'm canceling my we are
change membership really bro you gotta
do me like that you're taking you're
taking food out of atlas's mouth okay
what is my co-host going to do how is my
co-host going to eat and you got to
support your your humble poor t-shirt
Fender okay if you don't support it
where who where else are we gonna get
the t-shirts so do you do you still
shoot out of your RV when you're in
Florida do you ever go outside yeah
absolutely I mean that's like one of the
reasons you know the beach the Sun the
environment the people there it's
amazing but Atlas is always behind me
when I shoot my video so she's my
co-host she's awesome Feed the Beast
yeah I can't see any of the older super
chats surge is a gatekeeper I'm not
gatekeeping you guys are talking so much
that I can get away
we're trying to we're trying to get rid
of the Dead air here come on oh that's
not my fault I'm trying to I'm trying to
switch and read these old chats and do
this come on do me wrong right now
everyone David
tarantanto he says Toronto Tehran yeah
Toronto Crowder doesn't have to sign it
DW is a business they want a profit it's
effing life I hope Crider Crowder stays
solo but it's a business I think that's
a lot of people don't realize it as a
business that's important they offer a
the big ask they give them a really huge
lopsided contract he comes back with a
low ask and being like no no no put it
there then they find their way into a
middle I mean that's business yeah
there's another one here from Epstein
robco which I really just want to read
because that's all right yes
I'm wearing a hat right now that says uh
oh man I wanna can we is that company
exist can we make a rope company called
Epstein we sure that'd be hilarious it
just it just breaks doesn't work every
time you try to use it it just collapses
anyways uh Epstein roboco said you have
DC Drano here and you're wasting our
time talking about contracts I don't
think we're wasting our time what do you
think there's a big crowd you know we
brought out my Hollywood expertise there
but uh listen it's it's it's an honor to
be here and I'm happy to provide that
part of me uh you know everything else I
do is I post it out there so people know
we also have the after show as well guys
so if you want to see the after show we
don't have to be censored and be on the
YouTube under YouTube's whip you can see
us talk about more uh more cool stuff
there you go uh we have another one too
from Kevin Brady Crowder has missed a
ton of time in the past uh from this
from his show I don't think it's out of
touch to say that they Factor the
penalty in to incentivize to incentivize
doing the show consistently but he had
like medical reasons you know yeah yeah
heart surgery or something yeah
yeah but I guess here's the problem with
these contracts you can't expect the
daily wire to pay
up for a show that can't be produced but
the daily wire shouldn't expect to buy a
show if they can't assume those risks
like if I hire someone to work for
timcast and they get sick and I can't
work it's like okay well I can't I don't
stop paying them yeah it's happened to
me I was like a bunch and like a little
month or so ago you know we here at
timcast have unlimited sick time and
unlimited vacation time because we're
one of those one of those hippie
communist companies everyone makes fun
of where the the woman walks in like
here's my wine dispenser and like we got
an espresso machine downstairs did you
did you see Sam Hyde's video making fun
of that yesterday it was great it was
awesome one of the funniest yeah here's
a good one from um Marquette Asha Med I
hope I pronounced that right Marquette
uh Ian what's your opinion on the
Wizards of the Coast draft of the open
game license 1.1 great question it is
abhorrent that they're trying to take
control
retroactively of people's content that
they had already signed under open
gaming license 1.0 saying that they had
the right to own it so Wizards is doing
owner of Dungeons and Dragons is saying
we're gonna change our open game license
that said anyone can use DND rule sets
create their own versions sell it
monetize it create companies we're gonna
change that retroactively and now say
you owe us a percentage of your work
Crosslands will be open source gotta be
tabletop RPG and card game hell yeah so
but there's been a lot of pushback in
the dungeons dragons Community against
this opengl license 1.1 it may not
happen they were fishing how do we do
that how can we make an open source card
game and and tabletop RPG I'd have to we
would open source the rules set right
and then but they'd still have to be
like
a vote every what six months on like
updates well what you could do is make
it like free saw free license code so
that anyone could use it and make
changes but all the changes are also
free so that anything that ever
iteration of it gets used will also be
available and then one might be like one
version might become really popular
everyone let's play but there could be
side versions yeah we should do
something like that that'd be cool the
card game I think open sourcing is the
way to go instead of us trying I love
Magic the Gathering it's a fun game but
boy did they just just beat that game to
death also Wizards of the Coast same
company so I'm like can we make a
strategy card game
that's just open source
yeah but I don't I don't know how that
would work I don't know how that would
work because it would be just the art
would you could plug in your own art and
card names but it would still be if the
stats
so it could be that the rules and the
structure of the game is open source but
the actual cards will be made by like a
specific committee so like to construct
the game everybody we just get a big
community of people and they all pitch
the ideas and then we and then we have
this huge network of Open Source
individuals play testing and and hypo
you know theorizing then what we do is a
certain group of individuals the core
base which is a little bit elitist
ultimately decide on the cards
themselves offer them up to the
community for comment and game testing
and then the cards are free to print and
then we we could maybe even like sell
them as like I don't know I don't even
be able to do is not profit but I would
I would be interested in selling the
cards not to make a profit just to
produce someone's got to pay for the
printing
but like and there's got to be some kind
of standard to it but uh secondary
Market would cover costs a lot of things
how can we do it that'd be fun be
interesting if you guys have ideas uh
tweet them or message me at mines I know
that we could I started working on a
rule space with like instead of strength
intelligence and dexterity I've got like
uh aim uh speed you know I have
different skill stats and those things
could be open sourced if I could build
out like you roll a d10 if you have five
speed then you get five d10 when you
roll that's kind of white wolf styling I
know you love your rules yeah I am a big
status we're gonna grab one more here
this is from Caper 2x says Tim our free
AGS part of your employees benefits
package the world wonders the answer is
yes in fact we have like consistently a
hundred eggs on the counter and so I'll
walk in one day and be like guys take
the eggs take 18 grab a carton go home
with it go eat them I take advantage of
it I I at least have like two eggs a day
do you ever eat them raw amazing or do
you ever eat them raw you guys ever eat
them crack them into a string I haven't
done that no I scramble them and splash
a little vinegar in the pan and flip
around like Andrew grew told me to do
yeah Chef all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com because
you're supporting our work you're
helping me get sick time even though I'm
still working every day I took the
mornings off to try and rest my voice
and that's only possible because you
guys remembers
um
and uh your the coffee shop stuff we're
doing the game ideas everything we're
trying to do everything I believe in and
everybody here is impacting culture and
so a lot of you may have heard us you
know Ian and I talking about tabletop
games and other nonsense look imagine
the Gathering is one of the most popular
card games it's the OG card game easy
way for you to understand it if you're
not familiar is it's when you combine
poker and chess
so it's a strategy turn-based strategy
but you've also got that element of like
what's in his hand what's it guys he got
the card he's going to beat me and it
was extremely popular people who play it
they're not all like you know
role-playing or anything it's not like
cosplay it's like a strategy game but
they went woke they're getting woker and
this is really really bad for for
culture same thing with DND and now they
want to own people who make the content
it got bought Wizards of the Coast got
well d d got bought by wizard of the
coast then got bought by Hasbro so it's
like this corporate conglomeration is
Black Rock owns Hasbro so now we've got
these weird we want to make I want it to
be decentralized I don't want to be like
skateboarding of course there are
skateboard companies and you can buy
their boards but you can also make your
own board and you can skate I want to
make a game that can have a huge impact
on culture you go to you go to card
shops and you're playing the game but
there is no centralized owner of the
game there's a game format the rules the
elements of it are open source and
available to everybody and then the
popular versions exist and you know they
can maybe maybe it's like someone makes
their own card set and you can choose to
accept it or Canon or whatever we've got
to figure that part out but anyway this
is what we're doing and if you believe
in that you want to help us do things
like impacting culture making music you
know being uh impacting the skate
Community Building coffee shops being a
member helps you can also smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and uh you
can follow us at timcastirl you can
follow us at timcast DC adrenal you want
to shout anything out
I'm DC Drano on all the platforms and uh
well DC underscored right now yeah DC
underscore Drano you can follow me there
what's your Instagram again DC
underscore Drano thank you so much for
coming on that was great to really
appreciate you my website is youtube.com
forward slash we are change I did a
video on there that's doing really well
right now it is a deep dive on the world
economic Forum on Elon Musk and a lot of
the other crazier stuff that's happening
out there I got a big product launch
coming soon that's going to be really
funny and hilarious to stay tuned with
that and everything that I do check out
youtube.com forward slash we are change
see you there uh and I had a super chat
here from or it wasn't a super chat it's
just a from schutz that says gotta have
a mud wizard in Crosslands I kind of
like that mud wizard I'm going to write
that down uh any advice or in
information or ideas you give me will be
used at my soul discretion and will be
owned by me and uh or actually by Tim
Cass so keep that in mind everything's
going to be open source I have no
interest in controlling or owning any
kind of information in this state of my
life
um Rogan that was really awesome too we
did talk a lot about things that weren't
you tonight but I really enjoy hanging
out with you man hopefully we'll get to
do this again and I I have a feeling it
won't be the last time but it's been
awesome to finally meet you guys I have
a lot of respect and admiration for what
you're doing because like I was uh
saying before you know I speak to the
the Maga base I try to be a voice of the
Maga people but what the the audience
that you guys are reaching is the most
important because it grows this movement
for Freedom it's a big tent party and
you know I'm not touching I'm not
reaching people in the card games in the
video games and the skate shops and you
know so it's it's it's a team effort to
help save this country and I'm just uh
damn proud of what y'all are doing so we
we have to inspire young people
and if a young person goes to a comic
book shop today when I was a kid I'm 12
I go to a comic shop we were all when I
was 12 we were all rollerblading and I
would rollerblade to the comic book shop
I turned 13 I'm skateboarding all of a
sudden at the comic shop I'm watching
Dragon Ball Z I'm watching uh you know
Justice League and those were the things
that that inspired me when I was a
little kid Naruto and and think and Goku
and a lot of these anime uh mangas and
animes whatever you call it the plural
um the the character is always a like
it's always about someone underestimated
who has to work really really hard so uh
I'll give you I'll give you an example
um Black Clover is an anime I stopped
watching it but I really like it it's
this world where everybody eventually
gets a grimoire like not everybody but
some people have magic and the a book
will appear and like whoa and then the
book has magic spells they can cast this
one kid desperately wants to be you know
like a mage working for the king but he
has no magic powers so instead he works
out until he becomes this extremely
physically powerful dude and then he's
actually able to compete on a level with
people who have magic and then
eventually he does get like negative
magic whatever but he's just got a sword
and so what I really love about a show
like that is that he's up against all
these people who are either naturally
talented or were gifted things or are
prodigies and then he's always had to
work as hard as possible but he ends up
winning that's the kind of message kids
need to hear this dude like they show
him like just doing push-ups Non-Stop
and they're like making fun of him like
haha he has no magic and then he like
jumps so hard he shatters the ground and
it's like No One's Gonna Give You magic
you have to do the work that's why we
have to make games that's why we have to
skate that's why we have to make music
music because we don't want kids growing
up watching shows where it's like the
world is owed to you you can have
whatever you want you can even cut off
your own genitals and no no no we want
to tell people like the world is not
just the world's not fair we have to
work hard every day to bring that
fairness to bring Justice and if we are
going to be superheroes it's not because
you're an X-Man and you turn 13 and got
magic powers it's because you did a
hundred push-ups every single day and
you earned that that's the message you
got to give to kids that's what I'm
talking about so um you do we mention uh
did you pray yeah how do you pronounce
your last name exactly uh it's like it's
yeah Splurge is my is my legal search
actually yeah um but my name is Serge my
my name is pronounced dupriya my
internet name is.com d-o-t-c-o-i I keep
wanting to be like dupriya engage I love
that name dupriya hey thank you my my
parents would be stoked to hear you say
that uh surge.com I'm everywhere
search.com SoundCloud Instagram Twitter
I guess all this stuff I'm trying to be
more of a troll and be more annoying on
Twitter I understand Twitter humor now
careful though because in text they
don't understand the context oh yes yeah
uh too much sarcasm for for my own good
but uh yeah follow me there uh I will be
in the chat as always I'll be in the uh
in the comments or say rather and uh
yeah talk to you guys there thanks for
hanging out everybody Stephen Crowder
will be on this show on Monday so just
for those that made it this far in the
show and didn't dip earlier I will
confirm you've told them yeah yeah I'm
getting texts from the the crew and you
know I'm talking to Steven as well they
want to announce it well I just asked
him I was like is it okay if I tell
people you're gonna be on the show he's
like yeah uh so Steve will be here on
Monday soonest we can get him in really
excited uh glad to you know I think
everything's gonna be really really
awesome he's got a lot he wants to say
about this obviously we've given our
thoughts we're more of the fence sitting
you know milk those fence sitters on
this regard but uh you know Steven's
well invited to come and then um maybe
we'll end up having Jeremy back because
I I don't know I I like both these guys
so this will be interesting
um this should be fun we're gonna go to
the members only section thanks for
hanging out we'll see you all at
timcast.com cheers